Tim Ferriss: Wade, welcome
to the show. It is an honor
to have you. I've been meaning to reach out
for a very long time and I appreciate you
carving out the time in your schedule.
Wade Davis: Well, thanks very much,
Tim. It's great to be with you.
Tim Ferriss: And I suppose I should just say
as a bit of context, the catalyst for reaching out
was not one of your many TED Talks, although I've
listened to many. It was not One River, although
I'm familiar with that as well. It was actually
being gifted The Wayfinders by a friend of mine.
And I suppose just as a way of setting the stage,
if you wouldn't mind, could you explain the basic
intent of that book and the lectures that preceded
it? And I'm curious, since it was published
sometime ago, if there is one story that you
wish people would become familiar with, or a
chapter that you wish you could compel many,
many people to read at this point in time?
Wade Davis: Yeah, well that's a wonderful
beginning, Tim. The Wayfinders was a book
put together in a really wonderful tradition
in Canada called the CBC Massey Lectures.
And it's a fantastic event where once each
year they pick what they call a public
intellectual, and you're asked to give
five different talks in five different cities
before live audiences. Those talks are recorded
for broadcast on the radio three times during this
coming year, and then the lectures themselves are
wrapped up into a book. And it's kind of an
interesting thing because as opposed to most
public speaking, you've got a lot of things going
on. You're recording for live radio, you've got a
live audience, and you're also essentially
delivering the lecture that's already been
published and often is in the lap of the audience
if they've bought the book. But it's a great
tradition. Martin Luther King gave them, I was the
first anthropologist since Claude Lévi-Strauss,
The Wayfinders has a very conversational
style and I think that's one reason it's
been quite successful, and particularly for
college students. And the basis of the book
was really the mission that I had at the National
Geographic. I was very fortunate to be recruited
as the first class of what the Geographic
was calling their explorers and residents,
which is kind of an odd term because
none of us were ever in residence.
They wanted to demonstrate, personify
that they didn't just report science,
they generated science. And so that they
recruited seven individuals, Jane Goodall,
Bob Ballard, who found the Titanic, Sylvia Earle,
the great oceanographer, a host of incredible
characters, Johan Reinhard, the high-altitude
archeologist who found the Ice Maiden, a perfectly
preserved Incan mummy on Llullaillaco. And
they recruited me as a cultural anthropologist,
and it was very much part of a conservation
mission. In the second hundred years, having
told you about the world, National Geographic was
going to help you save the world. And my mission,
as defined in my contract, was to change the
way the world viewed and valued culture in a
decade. And the way to do that was not through
politics or polemics, but through storytelling.
Because storytellers, as you well know Tim,
change the world. And what we were trying to
share with the public was kind of the fundamental
revelation of anthropology. The idea that the
other peoples of the world aren't failed attempts
of being you. They're not failed attempts of being
modern. Every culture is a unique answer to a
fundamental question: what does it mean to be
human and alive? And when the peoples of
the world answer that, they do so in the
7,000 different voices of humanity. And all
those answers kind of collectively become
our human repertoire. And so we also wanted to
draw people's attention to the kind of haunting
fact that out of those 7,000 languages
spoken the day you, Tim, and I were born,
by absolute academic consensus, half are not being
taught to children. Which means they're moribund,
on the brink of extinction, if not exhaustion.
And that means in effect that we're living through
an era where half of humanity's
intellectual, social, spiritual,
even ecological knowledge is at risk. And at
the same time, and this is the amazing thing,
we're living through an era where geneticists have
finally proven it to be true what philosophers
and poets have always dreamt to be true, that we
really are all brothers and sisters. And I don't
mean that in the spirit of hippie ethnography. I
mean that studies of the human genome have shown
without doubt that the genetic endowment of
humanity is a continuum. Race is a total fiction.
We're all cut from the same genetic cloth. We're
all descendants of Africa, including those of us
who walked out of the ancient continent 65,000
years ago. But here's the astonishing thing.
If we're cut from the same genetic cloth,
by definition, we share the same genius.
And how that genius is expressed is simply a
matter of choice and cultural adaptation. And
so there is no hierarchy in culture. That old
Victorian idea that we went from the savage to
the barbarian to the civilized, to the Strand
of London. That Victorian societies sat at the
apex of a pyramid that went down to the so-called
primitives of the world, absolutely ridiculed by
modern science, shown to be an artifact of the
19th century, irrelevant to our lives today,
and as distant from those lives as the idea of
clergymen in that era who believed the Earth was
only 6,000 years old. So then the question is, how
do you share this? How do you reveal this kind of
wondrous thing about culture to the world? You
know, you have to show, you can't tell. Polemics
are never persuasive. So the reason that book, The
Wayfinders, it tells the story of the expeditions
that we did to share this message across the
world. And so we deliberately, and it wasn't easy,
we didn't want to simply go out as so many
ethnographic filmmakers tend to do, celebrating
the exoticism of the other. We really wanted to go
to places where the beliefs and practices revealed
this extraordinary universal truth. And I think if
you asked which was the most extraordinary of all,
and it would have to be the Polynesian Wayfinders.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that blew my mind.
Wade Davis: The type of story of the book. I mean,
this is just an amazing thing if you think about
it. Even today, members of the Polynesian Voyaging
Society can name 250 stars in the night sky. They
can sense the presence of distant atolls of
islands beyond the visible horizon just by
watching the reverberation of waves across the
hull of their sacred canoe, The Hōkūleʻa, this
great vessel that is a symbol of this Polynesian
renaissance. In the darkness in the hull,
they can distinguish as many as five different
sea swells, again, moving through the water,
distinguishing those caused by local weather
disturbances from those that pulsate across
the ocean and can be followed with the ease with
which terrestrial explorer would follow a river
to the sea. And each of these chapters in that
book, Tim, and the subjects also became films,
of course that we did for the Geographic.
I kind of tried to find, not a punchline,
but a kind of line that would sum it all up. And
so with Polynesia, it was very simple. If you took
all of the genius that allowed us to put a man
on the moon and applied it to an understanding
of the ocean, what you would get is Polynesia.
Tim Ferriss: I found it so striking, and I may be
using the wrong terms, that the captain and the
navigator were two entirely distinct functions.
And that's a great example to me of perhaps just
a fundamentally different way of viewing seafaring
when you come from a western lens. And I really
enjoyed that book. I encourage everybody to pick
it up. And if it's okay with you, I would love to
actually segue to another culture, another group.
Wade Davis: But Tim, before we leave Polynesia,
let me just add one thing that just to clarify
things for your listeners. The amazing thing
about this tradition was that it was based on dead
reckoning, which means that you only know where
you are by remembering how you got there. And it
was the impossibility of doing that that kept
most European transports hugging the shores of
continents until the British solved the problem of
longitude with the invention of the chronometer.
But we know that 10 centuries before Christ, from
an ancient civilization called Lapita, the ancient
ancestors of the Polynesians set sail into the
rising sun. And this idea of dead reckoning means,
and back to your navigator, why he's not running
the ship, because he or she must sit monk-like on
the back of the vessel, remembering every shift of
the wind, every tack, every sign of the sun, the
moon, the stars, the birds, the salinity in the
water, every one of these empirical observations,
and the order of their acquisition. And if that
memory chain is broken, the voyage can end in
a disaster. And all of this has to be done by an
individual who lives in a civilization that lacks
the written word. So all of this has to be placed
in memory over a three-and four-week voyage. Think
about that. Tell me that is not a form of genius.
Tim Ferriss: Not just a form of genius,
but a form of endurance. Almost beyond belief.
How many hours of sleep on average over the voyage
per day, or per night with that navigator get?
Wade Davis: It's a great question because they
kind of catnap in a way, but they can't really
do much more than just catnapping. It's funny,
this idea of sleep. We're so wired to the clock
that we feel that we've somehow done something
filthy or nasty if we only sleep four hours.
But many societies around — I spend a lot of
time in the Arctic, and one of the things that's
fascinating is that winter is a time for sleep,
the air of perpetual darkness. And summer, the
light is luminous all day long and it's not even
appropriate to sleep. You kind of catnap with
your dogs, but there's just too much to be done.
Tim Ferriss: So let's shift just a bit or
maybe entirely to the Kogi peoples of Northern
Colombia. You are deeply, deeply familiar
and intimate with Colombia and its people.
I had the opportunity through a
mutual acquaintance, Dr. Mark Plotkin,
to meet a mamo and small group of Kogi, but it
was a very cursory experience and they were very
select with their words and communication. Could
you describe the Kogi people of Northern Colombia
and perhaps just paint a picture for people
of what that culture and what those peoples
look like? Because I find them to stand
out, at least for me, amongst the cultures
I've been exposed to in a number of ways.
Wade Davis: Yeah, it's truly remarkable.
They live in Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta. The
highest coastal mountain range on Earth that
soars out of the Caribbean coastal plain to about
20,000 feet. There are four indigenous groups,
the Kogi you mentioned, the Wiwa, the Arhuacos,
and the Kankuamo. The Kankuamo in the 19th century
kind of cut a Faustian deal with the greater
Colombian society and endured a great deal of
assimilation. And they're kind of struggling
to get back to their traditional ways. But
the other three societies remain absolutely
extraordinary. And in a bloodstained continent,
you can almost say they were never conquered
by the Spanish fully. They are descendants of
an ancient civilization called Tairona, which
suffered immensely in the first decades of the
Spanish conquest. And the survivors fled into this
mountain massif where they lived almost in total
isolation, very little reference to them in the
colonial documents, for 200, if not 300 years.
And it's almost as if they had suffered so much
that they made a kind of collective vow never
to screw up again. And I think that accounts for
their intense religiosity. Many people call them
the Tibetans of South America, but they live
to this day inspired by a ritual priesthood,
the mamos, the sun priests. And the training for
the priesthood is extraordinary. It was first
reported in the 1940s by Reichel-Dolmatoff that
the acolytes were taken away from their families
at the age of two and three, and then sequestered
in the shadowy world of darkness for 18 years
during which time they absorbed the religious
beliefs of their society. And it's their sincere
convection that those beliefs, those rituals,
those prayers literally maintain the cosmic, or we
might say the ecological balance of the world. And
according to Reichel, after 18 years in which the
world only existed as an abstraction, the young
acolyte was taken out and taken on a journey.
And for the first time in his life at the
age of 18 or 19, he saw the horizon. He saw
the mountains, he saw the sun, and suddenly the
priest who has trained them all these years says,
"You know it's that beautiful, as I've promised
you. It's yours to protect." Now this was almost
a fable within anthropology because Reichel
never saw the ritual. He never went on one of
those pilgrimages to the Heart of the World. Then
an amazing thing happened. I first lived with the
Arhuacos when I was a lad of 19 and 20.
In fact, when you mentioned, it's amazing,
I've now been close with them for
almost 50 years. They, in fact, the
Arhuacos call me their Mamo Occidental. I was
once with President Santos, the Nobel laureate,
the first time he ever visited Nabusimake. And
the mamos had asked me to be there to welcome him,
and I hitched a ride in the presidential plane.
And when we got to the community, there was a
kind of formal ceremony in which the president
introduced his invitados, his ministers and so on.
And he got around to me and he couldn't have been
more generous with his praise and his kind words,
but he was interrupted by one of the mamos who
said, "You don't have to tell us about that guy.
He's our ambassador in North America." And so
I have a very wonderful relationship to them.
But here's what was extraordinary. In one wintry
day in Washington, the Colombian ambassador then,
Carolina Barco, a good friend of mine, turned up
at my office at the Geographic with a political
leader, Danilo Villafañe and three mamos, one
from each of the three cultures. Wiwa, Kogi,
and Arhuaco. They were there because the BBC had
made a film and the Arhuacos felt they hadn't had
their say and they wanted to make their own film.
So they'd come to me and as I'm looking at this
guy, Danilo, he looks so much like an old
friend of mine. So I pulled out a book of mine,
One River, which happened to have a photograph
in the frontispiece of one of the chapters. And I
showed him the photo and that was Danilo's father,
and who was murdered by the paramilitaries. And
I said to Danilo, "Son, you don't remember, but
when you were a little infant, I carried you on
my back for weeks up and down the mountains with
your father." And he was so touched by that and
the connection was so strong that he invited us
to do what I would've thought was the impossible.
To actually go along on a journey to the Heart
of the World and make a film about this idea
and the pilgrimage. And the idea is very simple.
As you come out of the sacred temple — and what
we discovered is they don't stay 18 years in
the darkness, but 18 years in seclusion around
the temple and a ritual diet, not seeing women.
And then they do go from the temple to the ice,
and from the ice back to the sea, and from the
sea back to the temple, completing this sort of
sacred devotional pilgrimage of the divine.
And we made that film. Unfortunately at the
very penultimate stage of the pilgrimage, we were
kind of ambushed by the FARC and we had to escape
and turn our cameras over to one of the Wiwa
lads that we had trained in cinematography.
And with incredible skill, he finished those
segments of the film. So we actually had the
entire pilgrimage documented. But I think there's
a bigger point to make about the elder brothers,
as they call themselves. They dismiss all of us
who have ruined the world as the younger brothers.
And these are societies that do not view the world
through an extractive paradigm. They do not think
that the world is just a kind of a stage set upon
which only the human drama unfolds. They don't
buy into the old Descartesian idea that all that
exists is mind and matter, and that only things
that can be measured can exist. That whole kind
of idea that we develop in the European tradition
that has now become so dominant, so powerful,
so ubiquitous, but it is not the norm. It is
highly anomalous. Most societies interact with
the natural world through the kind of metaphor of
reciprocity. Some idea that the Earth gives its
bounty to us. We owe our fidelity to the Earth.
And that's very much how the mamos see their role
as representatives of the natural order of things.
It's funny, when I was first asked by them to go
and be there, when President Santos arrived, one
of my close friends, a man called Mamo Camilo,
said to me something very profound.
He said, "Peace won't matter,"
and this is after 50 years of Colombia's horrific
war. "Peace won't matter if it's only an excuse
for the three sides to come together to maintain a
war against nature. It's time for us to make peace
with the entire natural world." And as we flew up
to Valledupar on the presidential jet from Bogota,
all of the president's aides were peppering him
with statistics for his speech in the community
that was going to be broadcast internationally.
And I kind of sheepishly put up my hand and I
said, in Spanish, "President Santos, for the
mamos, statistics don't matter a rat's ass.
What they care about is what's in your heart."
And then I told him what Mamo Camilo had said.
And President Santos, an incredibly wonderful
man, incorporated that and made that the theme
of his speech that went out that day to the world.
Tim Ferriss: I was very struck by, and I don't
want to spend too much time on this, but I'll just
say, struck by how central pagamientos — offerings
and payments — seem to be to certainly the mamos,
but broadly speaking, the Kogi. And I appreciate
all the context that you just provided. I would
also love you, and we could spend five hours
just discussing what I'm about to bring up. But
I also would love to ask you about coca. So many
people are familiar with coca as a leaf that is
chewed or something that has turned into cocaine.
But could you talk a bit about mambe? So
this is a word and something that has come up
in my radius a number of times, but what is mambe?
Where is it used? How is it prepared?
Wade Davis: Coca is a generic term for
two different cultivated species and four
different varieties that have been exploited
by people in South America, perhaps as long
as 8,000 years, certainly 5,000 years. And I
should say that coca is to cocaine what potatoes
are to vodka. And the two main types of coca,
one is called Colombian, that's Erythroxylum
novogranatense, and the other is a classic coca
of the Southern Andes, of Cusco and Lapas, that is
Erythroxylum coca. Now in pre-Columbian times, a
variety of that was taken down the Amazon into the
jungles of the northwest Amazon. And this variety,
which is known as Erythroxylum coca variety ipadu
is cultivated vegetatively, not from seed. It also
has half the alkaloid concentration. And so in a
very interesting way, the peoples of the Anaconda,
all these extraordinary societies, the Barasana,
Macuna, Tukano, Cubeo, Ticuna, I mean there's
scores of these extraordinary cultures.
They've learned to take the leaves,
roast them over a clay griddle, and then rather
than taking the leaf orally and mixing some kind
of alkaline with it, baking soda or limestone
or ashes of certain plants, as you'll see in
the mountains of southern Peru, they add the ash
of the leaves of the tree known as yaruma. And
then they pound the two together until you
get a very fine powder, which becomes even
more fine when sifted through palm fiber. It's the
consistency of talc. And with mambe then, you take
the actual coca with a bone like this. This is a
mambe bone right here. And you put the wad onto
your mouth and you let the saliva kind of soften
it and you don't really talk or breathe, or the
whole works will just explode as a green cloud.
And as it's moist, you then lift it up as a quid.
And the advantage of course is that by taking coca
in this way, you absorb the entire plant and thus
all the nutrients. I mean one of the, just be
before I just finish that, then the other coca,
the coca of the Kogi that we talked about, that
is Erythroxylum novogranatense, it's the coca of
Colombia. And that coca was taken down the coast
to Trujillo in the northern desert of Peru. And
that became the preferred coca of the Inca.
It's got a little wintergreen oil in it, it's
Erythroxylum novogranatense variety truxillense,
and that of course was a preferred coca that to
this day, Coca-Cola imports each year by the
ton allowing their beverage to really be the
real thing. The fascinating story, Tim, is
that I worked with Tim Plowman, a protege of
my professor Schultes, Mark's professor, in the
'70s, and we were charged to work out the botany,
the ethnobotany, the ethnography of coca.
And at that time we thought that the coca
of Colombia, for classic botanical reasons, was
derived from the coca of Peru. But now that we
have DNA, we see a greater story. It turns
out that these two sacred plants used for
8,000 years, revered as a divine leaf of
immortality by every culture in the Andes,
all come from the same wild ancestor, a
species known as Erythroxylum gracilipes,
which grows along the eastern flanks of the
Andes. Now that may seem like arcane botany
talk to many of our listeners, but it's actually
a miracle. Because to have two revered plants
independently domesticated through a process of
artificial selection, thousands of miles apart,
and yet each deemed to be sacred essence
of the divine, is unheard of. No precedent
in all of the history of botany and of human
cultures. And so this is the richness of coca.
Now, the extraordinary thing is that the
efforts to eradicate coca fields began 50
years before there was a cocaine problem. In
the 1920s, physicians in Lima in particular
looked up into the Andes and their concern for
the well-being of Andean people was matched in
intensity only by their ignorance of Andean life.
And when they saw illiteracy, poor sanitation,
one social pathology after the other, they had
to find a cause. And because issues of economics,
land distribution, inequity came too close
to challenging the bourgeois foundations
of their lives in Lima, they had to find
the evil source. And the source was coca.
And they blamed coca for every ill in
the Andes. And through all those years,
these doctors and physicians and nutritionists
never did the obvious, a nutritional study to
show just what this plant actually had in it.
And when we finally did that in the mid-1970s,
Andrew Weil, Tim Plowman, Jim Duke at the USDA,
we discovered, horrified our backers at the DEA
and the US government, because it turns out
that coca has a tiny amount of cocaine in it,
absorbed benignly as a mild stimulant by the mucus
membrane of the mouth, absolutely without harm.
The plant also has more calcium than any plant
ever studied, perfect for a traditional diet
without a dairy product. It also is chock full
of vitamins. It even has enzymes that enhance
the body's ability to digest carbohydrate
at high elevation, making it perfect for the
potato-based diet. So in one simple nutritional
study that could have been done at any time,
we put into stark profile these hideous efforts
that are underway, to this day, to destroy the
traditional fields. And we showed that this
was a plant that had been used with no evidence
of toxicity, let alone addiction, for at least
5,000 years. And so one of our big efforts today
is to decouple coca from cocaine and create a
nutraceutical market for the plant that will give
a legal market for the 150,000 families in
Colombia alone that depend on cultivating
coca for their survival. And also through taxes
may just give Colombia the revenue necessary to
pay the cost of peace, having drained its treasury
for 50 years to pay the cost of a war only made
possible by the sordid profits of prohibition.
Tim Ferriss: So we may come back to coca, and
as you're discussing the nutritional profile, it
makes me also think of the role that coffee serves
in some populations in the world. But I would love
to go to some well-trodden ground, and this is out
of personal curiosity and also because I think
that many people will want to hear more of the
background here. And then we're going to probably
come to discuss a number of mentors of yours.
But I would love to hear you expand on TTX and
Datura stramonium, if I'm pronouncing that right,
and how you came across these two in combination.
Because I think Datura stramonium, also known as
Jimson weed, if I'm not getting that —
Wade Davis: Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: — incorrect, grows right in
my driveway in Texas. It's found in all
sorts of places. TTX, a little less
so. But could you just provide the
background on where you came across these two?
Wade Davis: Sure. This is an incredible story,
a kind of an assignment of a lifetime that
would completely change my trajectory. I had
done a lot of work in the Amazon, three years
in fact, through the Andes and the Amazon.
And I had studied anthropology, but I never really
understood the real message of anthropology until
I went to Haiti. I'll explain that in a moment.
But what happened is that a very well-known
psychopharmacologist by the name of Nathan Kline,
psychopharmacology being the study of the action
of drugs on the brain, had been going to Haiti
for many years. The psychiatric institute bore
his name. He had set it up. A close colleague
of his at McGill University, Heinz Lehmann,
had a former student, Lamarque Douyon, who is
now the director of that psychiatric institute.
And Douyon was fascinated by the Haitian zombie
phenomena, and of course by folkloric belief,
the zombie is a living dead. It's an individual
who has had their soul stolen by sorcery,
kind of propelled into a perpetual state of
purgatory, said to be associated with enslavement.
And this was sort of something very much
from the realm of the phantasmagoric.
But Douyon had been paying attention and
investigating every case that came his way.
And finally he discovered this remarkable
story of a man called Clairvius Narcisse,
who in the early 1960s had been misdiagnosed
dead, or he been diagnosed dead by two physicians,
both American-trained and one an the American, in
the Albert Schweitzer Hospital in Central Haiti,
an American-directed institution that keeps
impeccable records. And this man claiming
to be Narcisse later walked into his village in
about 1980, '81, claiming to be the long-lost
brother. The family member had no doubt, but they
immediately told him to get lost and he had to
escape to the police station for his own safety.
And when Douyon looked into this, he was able to
secure death certificates. Scotland Yard verified
with their forensic expertise, the fingerprints
that belonged to the sister of the deceased.
There were a score of lines of evidence
that suggests that this man clearly had been
misdiagnosed dead and somehow turned up in the
realm of living. And in fact, Douyon went to the
family members and put together a questionnaire
of intimate information of the family background,
all of which this man answered correctly. So the
bottom line is that Douyon and Lehmann and Dr.
Kline went public saying they felt they had found
the first zombie. Now that drew their attention
to reports of a folk poison that was said to
bring on a state of apparent death so profound
it could fool a physician. Now this poison
wasn't just mentioned in travelers' accounts and
missionary memoirs and in ethnographic reports,
it was specifically mentioned in the penal code
of the country. But Douyon had not been able to
find the poison. He hadn't secured a formula
of it. And this was key to the whole question
of the Haitian zombie. It was either something
from the realm of fantasy or if it was real,
there had to be a natural product. And if that
product existed, that could make someone appear
to be dead such that they could come back in
the realm of living undamaged, that had huge
potential medical applications as Kline saw it.
So they came to Harvard, Schultes said he was too
old to go, but he said he knew someone who could
do the job. And that's how I was hired to go down
to Haiti to secure this poison. Now remember,
I wasn't looking for a poison that could kill
people. Lots of things can do that. I was looking
for something much more rare, which was a poison
that could bring someone to the state of apparent
death so profound, it could fool a physician and
yet the victim could survive. And so I did what
one does. I contacted a sorcerer who was very — he
had been described by the BBC as the incarnation
of evil. He was nothing of the sort. He had a
whorehouse and a bunch of Dominican women and he
had been a junior member of the Tonton Macoutes.
But I was able to establish, through a little
bit of theatrics, a good relationship with him.
Tim Ferriss: What was the group
that you mentioned? I'm not
familiar with it. A junior member of what group?
Wade Davis: The Tonton Macoutes. Tonton in Creole
means "Uncle." Macoute means "shoulder bag."
This was the nickname for the volunteers for the
national security. The militia that was set up by
François Duvalier in the wake of his presidential
election in 1957. And this is a pivotal part
of the story because Duvalier was the first
president in a hundred years to say that Vodou
was legitimate religion. He had Vodou temples in
the presidential palace. He wore the costume
of Baron Samedi, the guardian of the dead,
of the graveyard. He played Vodou like a
charm. And he used the secret societies
as his base of power. And from them, as my
research would discover, he created this notorious
force, the Tonton Macoutes. And it means that if
you misbehave, they will come and take you away in
their shoulder bag. And so I went out with Marcel
after this bit of theater that we did to — it was
kind of funny. I'll tell you about it sometime —
Tim Ferriss: I want to hear about the
theater. Yeah. How do you develop a rapport?
Wade Davis: Well, what happened was I went to
him with a good friend of mine, Max Beauvoir, who,
when he died, was sort of heralded as a Pope of
Vodou, an amazing kind of conduit for the outside
world to understand Vodou. And again, I should say
right off the top, Tim, that we have this idea of
Vodou from the movies. It couldn't be more wrong.
And just think for a moment, if we were asked
to name the great religions of the world, what
continent would we leave out? Sub-Saharan Africa.
And of course, Vodou is not a black magic cult.
It's a Fon word from Dahomey or Benin that means
"spirit" or "god." It's just the distillation of
very profound religious ideas that came over
during the era of slavery and then became
transformed within the soil of a new world.
That's why you have Hoodoo in the American South,
Candomblé in Brazil, Obeah in Jamaica, and so on —
Santería in the DR, and of course, Vodou in Haiti.
And Vodou took a particular strong form in
Haiti because as opposed to the other countries
I mentioned, Haiti was an independent Black
country, the only one in the world for a century,
gained its independence in 1804. And at that
time, much of its population, the slaves,
had literally been born in Africa. So in many
ways, you can almost argue that Haiti's more
Africa than Africa itself at this point. But at
any rate, I saw Marcel and he made me the powder,
but I knew the way he made it, the ingredients,
that it was kind of bogus. And so instead of
telling him that, I doubled what I had
promised to pay him, and as I left the
hounfour, the temple, I mentioned I was
going to try it on an enemy I had in the
capital and I'd let him know how it worked.
And then with a deliberate piece of theater,
Max Beauvoir and I stormed back a week later and
screamed and yelled at him that we had nearly
gotten killed, that his powder was worthless,
so he couldn't do a thing. And of course he,
then, got furious and he went into the inner
sanctum in the temple and came out with a bottle,
a little vial. And he said in Creole, "If
you don't think I know how to make poison,
drink this, you won't walk out of here alive."
And then all the Dominican girls started going,
"Bwè! Bwè! Drink, drink, drink!" And it
was a bit tense. And so I said to Marcel,
"Look. It's not that you don't know how to make
good poison. I came all this way because I know
you can. I'm just saying what you made me is
garbage. And if you give me garbage, you'll
never see me again. But if you give me the real
thing, you might make a lot of money from us."
And then I walked out. And I went back the next
day and the proper ingredients were drying on
the clothesline. And then we went into the inner
sanctum, the temple, and he took a bottle of raw
alcohol with human remains in it and all kinds of
animals and gore of one sort or the other, and he
handed it to me and I took a big drink and handed
it right back to him. And he laughed. And I think
it was the first time of many times that a Haitian
would say to me, "Ki kalite Blan say ou?" — "What
kind of White are you, anyway?" And so
that was the beginning of my relationship.
Tim Ferriss: Were you not
worried about drinking that?
Wade Davis: No.
Tim Ferriss: What
was the expectation of the ingredients?
Wade Davis: Well, it was just a ritual
vessel of magical things.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Wade Davis: He's a sorcerer, a negative
priest, and it's all been pickled in
sugar cane alcohol. Part of it is, it's not like
macho. It's actually a more subtle, more poetic,
more beautiful thing. Tim, how do you break down
the barrier between yourself and the people with
whom you find yourself living as a guest? And
it's never bravado or macho. It's actually always
love and empathy and letting people know that you
believe they're somebody. And it seems so simple,
but you'd be astonished how many people
I encountered, particularly in Haiti,
including Dr. Kline, who had no way whatsoever of
hanging out with those folks, just couldn't do it.
And that's what I've been doing all my life. But
the important thing is, from the Haitian point
of view, the poison is not what makes a zombie.
And that's really important and that explains
how I got the formula so quickly. But the funny
part of this story is that it was Easter Sunday
when I returned to the United States through JFK
airport, and I had this suitcase made of surplus
7UP tin cans that was filled to the gunnels with
human bones, all the ingredients in various forms.
I had a live Bufo marinus toad in my backpack,
the biggest toad in the world, 10 inches across,
and I had no permits. And you couldn't do —
Tim Ferriss: Customs dream.
Wade Davis: Yeah. You couldn't do this post
9/11. But I went up to this customs agent and
I just said, "Well, let's just see what he says."
So I opened up this thing, so only he could see
it. And he slammed it shut, Tim. And I'm not
going to give you exactly what he said because
they are children listening to your podcast.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no. This doesn't need to be
family friendly. What did he say? You can tell us.
Wade Davis: He literally said in a New York
accent, "Look, it's Easter fucking Sunday. I
didn't even want to work fucking work today.
I don't know who the fuck you are. Just get the
fuck out of here." And that's how the zombie
poison came into America.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Thank
God for Easter Sunday and that guy.
Wade Davis: But then here's where we
get to your TTX. I analyzed the plants, took the
reptiles to the herpatologist and all the various
creatures to the various specialists. And I
finally got around to the fish. And I went to see
the ichthyologist in the basement of the Museum
of Comparative Zoology. And this was like out of
a movie. And I say to this wonderful character,
"Did you find anything in those fish?" And he
had his head inside a white shark. And as he heard
me, he bounced his head against the teeth, pulled
his head out and said, "I thought you were the
poison people" because our museum was the world
center for the study of medicinal toxic plants and
hallucinogens, and then he goes to the shelf and
he doesn't pull out The Journal of Ichthyology,
he pulls out a pocketbook dimestore novel,
and it turns out to be written by Ian Fleming.
And it was either From Russia with Love or from
Dr. No. And at the one end of those two books, 007
gets kicked in the shin by the bad guy and dies
and he comes back to life in the next book because
he's been kicked with the poison tetrodotoxin. And
that is what blew open the zombie study.
Tim Ferriss: TTX. Tetrodotoxin.
Wade Davis: Right. Because tetrodotoxin is a big
molecule that selectively blocks sodium channels
and brings on peripheral paralysis, dramatically
low metabolic rates, and consciousness is retained
until death. And when you looked at the symptoms
of Narcisse, they match perfectly the symptoms
of victims of fugu fish poisoning in Japan. The
fugu fish is a culinary delicacy. The chef must
eliminate most of the TTX, but not all, because
he wants the connoisseur to enjoy the pleasant
after effects of a mild intoxication. But because
some people screw up, lots of people have died.
And there was a whole literature in Japan and
in the public, in newspapers, case after case
after case, of people nailed into their coffins
by mistake. So this changed everything. This
suggested without doubt that the sorcerers in
Haiti had found, in their environment, a natural
product that not only could make someone appear to
be dead, but had done so many times in the past.
So then you had to ask, what really is a zombie?
Who's controlling the process? And the end,
I was able to become the first person from outside
of Haiti ever to be initiated into the Bizango,
Sanpwèl, the secret societies that produced
the Tonton Macoutes, and I was able to at least
suggest that zombification was a form of ultimate
social sanction in which the individual lost their
personal autonomy and their physical freedom and
became cast into a state of purgatory that was,
in a sense, worse than death.
So just before we leave zombies,
the whole purpose of this was, let's define the
drugs used to make zombies because no drug can
make a social phenomena, but rather to take a
phenomena that had been used in an explicitly
racist way, to denigrate an entire culture and
its religion, and to try to make sense out of
sensation. And so if the scientists sent me to
Haiti to find the chemicals used to make zombies,
I found myself instead studying the psychological,
social, historical, political dimensions of a
chemical possibility. And that's what made
the research so exciting. The pursuit of that
little preparation opened up these historic and
ethnographic vistas that no one had seen before.
Tim Ferriss: I have two questions related to
this, and I'm sure we could have dozens more,
but there are so many other things I'd love to
chat about. But two follow-up questions. The
first is, what role, if any, does the Datura play
in this entire process? And there are documented
deaths every year, in the United States at least,
related to people who attempt to DIY some type of
trip from Datura. So the role of Datura, if any.
And then secondly, and this is based on a somewhat
fragmented recollection of watching some type
of news program that was purportedly covering
this social phenomenon of zombification.
And my impression from that was that some
people remain in servitude for other people as
zombies for an extended period of time. And I'm
wondering if there is — what are the primary
contributing factors to a situation like that?
Wade Davis: Well, one of the things you always
have to do in this kind of research is separate
what we might call the emic from the etic, which
are unnecessarily technical terms in anthropology,
the view from within, the view from
without. Why don't the people in India eat
cows? Well, it's prohibited by the scriptures,
but also they need the oxen to work the
fields. Those would be the two points of view.
First, let me answer your question about Datura.
Datura is in the solanaceae, the potato family,
the family of choice of black magicians around the
world. The tree Daturas, the brugmansias in South
America, are known as the jaguar's intoxicant,
the tree of the evil eagle. And these plants have
in them powerful tropane alkaloids, scopolamine
and atropine in particular, that induce a state
of psychotic delirium, visions of hellfire,
a burning thirst, amnesia, a sensation of flight.
These are incredibly dangerous and horrific
plants that the shaman in the Andes
take only if everything else fails,
almost with the idea that just in touching the
realm of madness, they might achieve illumination.
And what's interesting, and going back to
the victims of tetrodotoxication in Japan,
if you eat fugu fish and you get poisoned
and you're put into your coffin and you're
lucky enough to be rescued, you come out of the
coffin and you say, "Oh, that's terrible. What a
mistake. I'll never eat fugu again." But that's
the end of it, right? But remember, the Haitian
doesn't sit around questioning whether zombies
exist. He or she knows in the fiber of their
being that they do and or she knows why
a zombie is made, a form of punishment
within the traditional culture. And so we don't
know exactly what might or might not occur.
We know that tetrodotoxin reaches a crisis in
about six hours. And if you survive that crisis,
you have no physiological damage whatsoever. But
of course, in the case of the Haitian zombie,
whether the individual is symbolically put
into the ground, placed behind a shade or
hidden from view, whatever, when they come out of
the tetrodotoxication, they know what's happened
to them and they're in a state of incredible
suggestibility and fear. And what the Datura
may serve, it's known as the konkonm zonbi,
the zombie's cucumber. And I was at least
told by many informants that at that point of
disorientation, the victim is given Datura, which
must be an extraordinary, horrific experience,
and one that would sort of seal the psychological
conviction that he or she had, in
fact, been punished in this way.
Now, when you mentioned the idea of slavery,
well, there's no incentive to create, in Haiti,
a force of indentured labor. But again,
critically given the colonial history,
slavery implies a destiny almost worse than life
itself. And by the same token, I mentioned earlier
that they don't believe the poison creates a
zombie. To make a zombie, I have to capture, Tim,
your little good angel, your soul, the soul that
makes you Tim Ferriss as opposed to the soul that
makes me Wade Davis, not the soul that we both
share, that all sentient beings share, but the
soul that creates your personality. That's why
a zombie appears comatose. The fear in Haiti is
not of zombies, it's of becoming a zombie. And
so I once asked a Vodou priest, for example,
if it was just a matter of returning the soul to
the victim, could that be done and the person made
whole? And the man who I asked that question
was the great emperor of the secret societies.
He had been head of the Tonton Macoutes for
a fifth of the country. I once asked Herard
if during the revolution he had ever killed
anybody. He said, "I never killed any people,
just enemies." And so I asked him, "Couldn't
you just give the soul back to the person?"
And he said, "Yeah, you could do that. But
on the other hand, blan, if you were a woman,
would you want an ex-zombie to ask you to
dance?" And of course, what he was getting
at is that a zombie becomes a total pariah.
Now, remember what I said about Narcisse when
he first went back to his village. Nobody doubted
that it was the long-lost, presumed-to-be-dead
brother. But did they welcome him with open arms?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Wade Davis: No. They told him, "Get the
hell out of here." Because he had died
socially. He had died spiritually. They
wanted nothing to do with him. And that,
really, is what a zombie is all about.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, thank you for that. And
part of the reason I was asking about the Datura,
as I do have some familiarity with brugmansia
and have had some exposure to the Awajún or the
Aguarunas who use it pretty extensively for not
just dark purposes or power purposes, but for many
different conditions. But my understanding is that
also organized crime, I want to say in Colombia,
for a period of time, was using brugmansia seeds,
which I think they're called burundanga. They
would pulverize and someone with a map would walk
up to a mark and say, "Could you tell me where
this place is?" blow the powder into their face,
at which point that person would become highly
suggestible and also have developed amnesia.
So you could, say, take someone back to their own
apartment, ask them to help load their things into
a truck. They would have no recollection of this
even though they would be coherent interacting
with security guards. And for that reason, I was
wondering if, perhaps, the Datura was used in a
similar fashion to increase suggestibility?
Wade Davis: You're absolutely right on,
Tim. The word Datura, the name of the genus, comes
from ancient India. Bands of criminals known as
the Daturas who used it as a knockout drug.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. I did not know that. Wow.
Wade Davis: I was once in San Agustín with a
Colombian and this Australian kind of hippie guy,
this is back in the early '70s, and he spoke
about how he ate a bunch of tree Datura in his
hotel on the coast and ended up walking around
naked, the Barranquilla, a public market for
five days before he was finally arrested. And at
our table, Tim, there was a wonderful Colombian
hippie girl who looked up at me and said, "I know
that market. I wouldn't even buy a mango there."
But I'll tell you in my book, Magdalena, about
the Great River of Colombia, there's a story of
my good friend William Vargas, who was on
his way to university. And these stories,
like you recounted, are part of travelers' lore
in Colombia. But I had never met anyone who had
actually endured this. And someone on a bus
offered him a cake or a cookie, which he ate.
And that was the last thing he remembered. And
he came to four days later in a kind of psychic
horror, having lost everything that he owned and
had his entire psychological state shattered.
So these are very powerful drugs indeed.
Tim Ferriss: So I guess there are a few lessons.
Number one, don't take or accept candy from
strangers, everybody listening. And do not play
around with these plants and molecules. They are
no joke and can do a tremendous amount of damage.
So I would like to rewind the clock a bit.
And you mentioned Richard Evans Schultes.
I've had a number of discussions about him
on the podcast before, so he may come up,
but I would actually like to invoke a
different name, which is David Maybury-Lewis,
if I'm pronouncing that correctly. Could you
please describe who he was and what you learned
from him or what lessons he imparted to you?
Wade Davis: I was so incredibly fortunate, looking
back. I was an undergraduate at Harvard. I got my
PhD at Harvard, but I began as an anthropologist.
And David Maybury-Lewis was my undergraduate
tutor. He was one of the great Americanists. He
had traveled into the heart of Brazil in the 1950s
to live amongst the Xavante and, before that,
the Xerente, who at the time were said to be
the most feared indigenous groups in Brazil.
And he was a great humanist. And while I was with
him, he created Cultural Survival with his wife,
Pia. And he absolutely lived in a way, although
he wasn't really a Boasian because he was from
the British tradition of social anthropology.
But he absolutely believed that activism was an
integral part of the anthropological endeavor.
When you have languages disappearing, when you
have indigenous people suffering the predations
of the rubber era, there's a moral obligation to
both tell their stories and to work with them,
I think, as liaison, a conduit to the world,
facilitating or amplifying their voices,
bringing their concerns to the world.
And that was something that I had in the fiber
of my DNA because of my association with David.
I was also very fortunate, as you mentioned,
to fall into the orbit of Professor Schultes.
But Professor Schultes was a man of action
and deed. In 18 years of studying with him,
I don't think I ever had an intellectual
conversation. He would say things to you like,
"There's one river I'd like you to know," knowing
full well that the process of getting to that
river would involve experiences guaranteed
to assure you that if you emerge out of the
forest of that confluence alive, you'd be a wiser
and a more complete human being. But Schultes was
not a man of ideas. He was a botanist. That's
what he was, a plant explorer. And I loved
botanical exploration largely because it provided
the conduit to culture. If you want to live with
the Inuit in the high Arctic, you better become
a hunter, because that is a measure of a man.
If you want to engage the priests in Haiti,
you have to serve the Loa. You've got to become
part of the circle of Vodou. Otherwise, what
are you doing? And of course, in the Amazon,
the plants become the perfect conduit to culture.
You're not turning up at some maloca and saying,
"I'm here to study your sex life." If someone
turned up at our doorstep like that, we'd call
the police. But studying the plants makes so
much sense to those for whom the plants are so
important. At the same time, most ethnobotanists
of my generation were notoriously uneducated when
it came to the nuances of anthropology and
ethnography. And I was very, very fortunate
in having David, a mentor who carried all the way
through graduate school. I taught more courses
for David than I did for Schultes. And in fact,
my ideas that in the wake of all my botanical
research, I actually kind of discovered in the
wake of the Haiti work, that what I was really
interested in was culture as opposed to plants.
I always still use plants to inform much
of my writing, but it was the ethno part of
ethnobotany that intrigued me. And in that sense,
all of my ideas that I have been exploring
through the 13 years at the Geographic,
the decade as a professor of anthropology
at the University of British Columbia,
everything traces back to David.
And on the subject of mentors,
I think this is so important for young people
listening to this broadcast. I grew up in
the simplest of middle class homes. My father's
spirit, in many ways, had been broken in the war,
as had my mother in a different set of
circumstances. There was a lot of love, but
not a lot of activity, creativity. And it was very
clear to me that I had to get out. And I began,
a very young age, jumping off cliffs.
And as Terence McKenna always said,
"The great lesson of life is that when
you do that, you don't land on rock,
you land on a feather bed. The world exists to
lift you up, not beat you down." Jim Whittaker,
the great climber, good friend of mine, said that
"If you're not living on the edge when young,
you're taking up too much space." But what I
found myself having to do, Tim, was fling myself
into the arms of mentors. And those mentors
could be an old Gitxsan elder who I recorded
mythology with and hunted with for 40 years.
It could be an engineer who taught me how to
understand the complexities of industrial logging
when I spent a year in the bush. I've always
believed that nothing is beneath you. Nothing is a
waste of time unless you make it so. A cab driver
can have as much to teach you as a professor at
university if you're open to the possibility.
And I always found that if I just gave
myself fully to these mentors like Schultes,
like David Maybury-Lewis, like Dr. Kline, and many
that I've had the privilege to engage since then,
I was able to become the most important thing,
which is the architect of my own life. And this
is what I say to young people, "Be patient,
never compromise, give your destiny time to
find you. Bitterness always comes to those who
look back on a life of choices imposed upon them
from the outside. And you may not make all the
right decisions, but if you own those decisions,
they all become the right ones because together
they become the path of your own creation and
you become the architect of your own life."
And that is something so very important. And in
that spirit, Tim, I try to do everything I can to
help young people. I answer every email and I get,
as you do, thousands of emails from young people.
And very often what they're saying, they may
have a specific question, but what they're really
saying is not just, "How can I be you?" They know
they can't be me. But what they really want to
know is, "How can I live a life of authenticity?
How can I live a life where I'm not strapped to
a laptop at a desk and a cubicle? How can I find
a way to monetize the creativity of my own life?
How can I make myself, and the act of being alive,
my vocation, recognizing that any job one has is
just a passing thing, a kind of filter through
which to see the world and only for a time?"
And the real challenge is to make the art of life
itself your vocation. And I always answer those
because if you don't answer, it's not a neutral
gesture. It's a slap in the wrist. They're
reaching out to you and all you have to say is,
"Wonderful idea, Charlie. Go for it. Your friend."
And that takes about as much time as deleting the
message. And I learned that from Schultes.
I'll tell you one wonderful story.
The most famous botanical collections of
Schultes, and Mark would certainly confirm this,
were between 1950 and 1953 when free of the
rubber emergency, he was free to collect medicinal
plants. He described the use of 2,000 medicinal
plants previously unknown to science. And with him
on all those collections was a man called Isidoro
Cabrera. Now, when you do botany and you collect
plants, the senior botanist's name goes first.
So Tim Plowman and Wade Davis, Plowman and Davis,
and that's how you do it on the specimens; it's
kind of a formal thing. But you never are said
to put an Indigenous helper on the label as
if he's an equal to you, but Schultes did.
He met Isidoro when Isidoro's farm had been
burned in the war. His parents had been murdered,
he had no food, he was absolutely nothing. And
he ended his life a full professor of botany with
multiple honorary degrees. And before he died,
when I was writing the book One River, I went
to see Isidoro in Cali. And I said, "Professor,
I want you to think really carefully. I want you
to remember the first moment you met Professor
Schultes in the forest, in Macarena. What was
it like? What did he say?" And he looked at me
very pensively, and then suddenly, there was a
twinkle in his eye, and he said, "He looked at me
like I was somebody." Isn't that beautiful, Tim?
Tim Ferriss: That is beautiful.
Wade Davis: And in class-riddled
Colombia at that time, for a Harvard professor
to do that, and it made that young man's life.
Pulled him out of misery, gave him a
career and a great gift to Colombia.
Tim Ferriss: What a story. And I
want to come back to, I suppose,
frames and lenses for a moment, and also Jim
Whittaker. So for those who don't know, the first
American to summit Everest, if my research is not
lying to me. And I'm looking at an excerpt from
alumni stories on the brentwood.bc.ca website,
and he comes up. And there's a line that I
would like to explore because I think it's Maya
Angelou, if I'm pronouncing her name correctly,
said that courage is the mother virtue that
unlocks all other virtues. Because effectively,
I'm paraphrasing here, but at the
breaking point, you need courage
to enact or to enable those other virtues.
And there's a line here, and I don't know if
it is Jim's or yours, but either way,
I would love for you to expand on it.
"Pessimism is an indulgence,
orthodoxy is the enemy of invention,
despair an insult to the imagination."
And I want to bring this up because
it strikes me that a lot of people, not
just very young people, but many people
overall feel a certain psycho-emotional malaise
right now, a sense of overwhelm that has led to
pessimism or nihilism. And so it seems
to me that optimism is the unlock here.
So could you elaborate on the "pessimism
is an indulgence" and so on in that line?
Wade Davis: Yeah, that was actually my
line, not Jim's. People are always asking,
we're always asking each other, "Are you
optimistic?" And I kind of feel like,
how can you not be optimistic? I mean, that's the
purpose of life itself. And if you're a father,
you absolutely have an obligation to remain
hopeful. And given how many gifts we have,
surely pessimism does become something of an
indulgence. We're all so caught in the present
these days, so little sense of history,
and we forget how much we've achieved.
But when you think about it, Tim, in my lifetime,
women have gone from the kitchen to the boardroom.
People of color, from the woodshed to the
White House. Gay people, men and women,
from the closet to the altar. When we think
of the environment, when I was a young kid,
just getting people to stop throwing garbage out
of a car window was a great environmental victory.
Nobody spoke about the biosphere or biodiversity.
Now these are terms familiar to schoolchildren. So
what's not to love about a world capable of such
social transformation, such scientific genius?
Just think about that moment on Christmas Eve,
1968 when Apollo went around the dark side of
the moon and emerged to see, for the first time
in human history, not a sunrise or a moonrise,
but an Earthrise. And in that incredible
moment, we suddenly saw the Earth as it is,
not this infinite horizon, but a fragile blue
planet, as the astronauts famously reported,
floating in the velvet void of space. And I
think everything has changed with that. Like
a flash of illumination, it swept over the
world. We never will think again about the
natural world in the same way we did before that
vision. And even today, as I mentioned earlier,
I think, the revelations of genetics, showing
us indisputably that race is a total fiction.
Well, that hasn't really gotten into
the zeitgeist yet as the moonshot has,
but it will. And I think that we're living
through extraordinarily exciting times
and extraordinarily challenging times. But as
I say to all young people, "What generation has
ever come of age in a world at peace, a world
without troubles?" It's very interesting. One
of the ways I, Tim, keep my optimism, my dad
wasn't a religious man. His spirit was broken
in the war. I never saw the inside of a church in
his presence. But he did believe in good and evil.
And he used to say to me, "There's good and evil
in the world. Take your pick and get on with it."
And it was incredibly wise, because we have
this sort of thing in the Christian tradition,
particularly, that if we just wait long enough,
good's going to triumph over evil and we'll all
somehow be dissolved in the Rapture. Well, ain't
going to happen. And famously, in Medieval times,
if you asked the obvious question, "If God's all
powerful, why does he allow evil to exist?" you
were burned at the stake for heresy. But in
the Indian tradition, the Vedic tradition,
by contrast, when Lord Krishna was asked
that very question, "If God's all powerful,
why does he allow evil to exist in the universe?"
Lord Krishna said to the disciple, "To thicken
the plot." In other words, good and evil walk
hand in hand. You're never going to lose one.
You've got to take your side. And the
purpose of life is not to triumph over evil,
but keep pushing the wheel of justice forward.
And when you realize that that is the end point,
you then never expect to win. And if you
never expect to win, you're not disappointed
when you lose. And because of that, you
can keep fighting with the same idealism,
the same energy when you're 69 years old, as
I am today, that I had when I was 20 years old
and marching against the war in Vietnam.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to discuss rites
of passage. And specifically, we don't have to
necessarily focus on this, but this is something
that often ends up on my radar of consciousness
because I have many males in my audience. And
there seems to be a distinct lack of rites of
passage for men in most westernized societies,
or many westernized societies. And I would love
for you to describe a chapter in your life,
and I'm most certainly going to butcher this
pronunciation, but Spatsizi. Did I get that right?
Wade Davis: Yeah, Spatsizi. Red Goat.
Tim Ferriss: So could you explain what that is?
Wade Davis: Before I jump into my, perhaps, story,
rites of passage exist all around the world for
a very specific reason. It's not a coincidence
or an accident that they involve pain, whether
it's scarification, whether it's the severing of
the foreskin, whether it's the pain of ordeal,
the ingestion — I mean, for example, the
Algonquins, speaking of Datura, their initiation
rite was to put the young lads in the long house,
seal it shut, and make them eat Datura for two
weeks, so that they would forget what it was
to become boys, to learn what it was to be men.
But the reason all these ordeals that you know so
much about, vision quests, et cetera, have pain
is because a message has to be clear: this is the
end. It's not about the twiddling of thumbs. We
are passing on to you the obligation of adulthood.
You now hold the destiny of our people in your
hands. This is not trivial. You best be prepared.
And I think whether it's with women who go through
their own rituals, which are always sort of
timed to the first menses or the first period,
fertility, transforming a girl into a woman,
a potential mother, or it's a boy proving his
manhood. Now this has become rather frowned
upon in our politically correct woke world.
But the truth is, young men, I've never known
a young lad who didn't want that challenge.
It's that idea of proving oneselves, not in
a gratuitously macho way, but literally in a
kind of organic way of grit and courage and
strength. And I think that's why. I mean,
for example, I've got very close friends in
the Navy SEALs, and they all have a kind of
calm confidence because they've been on what
Joseph Campbell called the Hero's Journey.
And I think those of us, like myself, brought
up in a society that we did not have obvious
outlets, we created our own hero's journeys.
And for me, it was always either through work or
travel. You mentioned Spatsizi. Well, I was living
on Haida Gwaii in Northwest British Columbia in
the mid-'70s. And I was very much critical of
industrial clear-cut logging, but I felt that
I best learn something about it. So I lied about
my credentials and managed to hire on as a logging
forestry engineer in one of the toughest logging
camps in the west coast of British Columbia,
where I stayed a year. And I learned everything
about the business, including the corruption.
And it was a fantastic experience because I
also learned that the men and women fighting
off hunger with a chainsaw were not my enemy.
And I learned that in all of these conflicts,
particularly around resources, there are
never any enemies, only solutions. But I
kind of escaped that camp, taking a job as the
first park ranger in what had just been created,
Canada's biggest roadless wilderness park. And my
job description was deliciously vague: wilderness
assessment and public relations. In two four-month
seasons, I saw 12 people. There was no one to
relate publicly to. And these travels to South
America. And even in Haiti, you have to understand
that during the course of that research, it
turns out I never knew who was paying for it all.
And I'll tell you, if you'd like, a story
of the night I had to light myself on fire.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I can't say
no to that. So yes, please.
Wade Davis: Well, remember I said I became very
close friends with Marcel Pierre, and we were
like brothers by the end of the many years I was
there. And his wife was dying of uterine cancer,
and he was so sad. He came to me and I
bought all this blood for her and she
still was dying. And I took him back to get
a tap-tap. And for once I was dressed like an
American tourist, and I didn't have —
Tim Ferriss: What is a tap-tap?
Wade Davis: Oh, a tap-tap's a local bus in Haiti.
And I went in my little Jeep and I didn't have my
wallet or any money. And I got a flat tire
after I dropped him off. And I said to this
guy at the side of the road who fixed tires
manually, I said, "Can you fix my tire?" He
starts fixing my tire. Then I say in Creole, "Nez
me pa gen kòb" — "I've got no money." And then he
said, "Ki kalite Blan say ou?" and he started
hassling me. And I just wasn't in the mood. I
should have not done this, but I took his hand
and I gave him the secret society handshake. And
then he blanched back and then he said again,
"What kind of white are you?" And then we had
a big laugh and he said, "Nou gen gwo lig aswè
a" — "We've got a big thing happening tonight."
And I'd broken down, by chance, right by a Bizango
chanpwel — secret society temple. So I went back
that night, for the first time unescorted by a
powerful Vodou priest. And the ceremony begins
like any ceremony with the invocation of Legba,
the spirit of communication. And the dances are
just Vodou dances. But then at midnight
you hear the fouet kash, the whip crack,
and the conch trumpet, the symbol of the
revolution, blow. And then the order goes out,
"Soldiers of the night, change skins!" — "Sòlda
nan lannuit ! Chanje la po!" And everybody goes,
hundreds of people, go into this temple and
emerge in these anonymous black and red robes.
And at that moment, six men came and grabbed me
and flung me into a chamber. And I rolled around
in the dust and I looked up and I was looking
at a table of emperors of the secret societies,
who wanted to know how I knew what I knew.
And I shared with them the iconography,
passwords, handshakes, but it was all too
much and too little at the same time. And
it was a very awkward moment and I had
to do something. I was there by myself.
And there's always a human skull with a candle
burning with a bottle of raw sugar cane alcohol,
the base of the poteau mitan, which
is used as a libation, not to drink.
So I just thought, I better do something. So I
very deliberately went over, took the bottle and
poured the alcohol all over my body, my back, my
hair, everything. And then very deliberately went
to the candle and lit myself on fire. And as
I flamed like a torch — remember, this isn't
kerosene or diesel, it's just like doing the same
thing with lighter fluid. There wasn't any danger
except I'd lose my eyebrows. But while I was
still a living torch, I went over and offered
the secret society handshake again to each of the
men. They loved it. Cracked up laughing. And after
that I couldn't go by that crossroads without
getting flagged down. [Haitian Creole]. And I
became very friendly with that temple, actually.
Tim Ferriss: Well, okay, so hold on. I mean,
that's a hell of a party trick. So how
did this occur to you? And I guess you
just had knowledge that that wouldn't pose any
grave danger. I certainly wouldn't. I mean,
having your body on fire seems dangerous.
Wade Davis: But no, you must have lit your fingers
on fire with lighter fluid when you were a boy.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't. I mean,
maybe I should. Never say never.
Wade Davis: Tim, maybe it's a Canadian
thing. I don't know. There are these moments, and
I don't mean in any way, because I keep saying,
"It's empathy and love, it's not bravado."
But I remember when I was 14, my mother was
a modest but determined Canadian woman, and she
worked all year as a secretary to raise enough
money to let me join a group of kids a language
teacher was taking to Colombia. And I was really
lucky because I was billeted in the mountains and
I never saw the other Canadian lads. And many of
them got what the Colombians called mamitas, or
homesickness. And I felt like I just finally found
home. I got drunk for the first time and kissed
a girl. I was in Heaven. But there was this real
bully in the valley. I was 14 and he was 17 or
18, and he kind of terrorized — he wasn't a bad
guy, [but] he terrorized all the kids.
And one day he challenged me to what they would
do is they put a cigarette — you put your forearms
together, put a lit cigarette in the middle,
and the first one to drop their arm is the loser.
He put the cigarette on, and I said, "This is
stupid, it hurts." He didn't understand that that
cigarette could have burned through my arm before
I would drop my arm. And of course I didn't drop
my arm. And eventually he had to drop his arm.
And that was kind of a gift from me to him
because he was never the same again. After
that he was a different character.
He didn't have to do that anymore.
And to this day, I still have that huge scar on
my forearm, but I don't ever regret having done
that. And what is wonderful about doing this
kind of field work is the dance of culture. How
do you find the rhythm? It's like dancing with
a woman for the first time. Sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't. I always say to young
students setting off to the field, "What you
need to do is just act like you would if invited
to someone's home at Thanksgiving. Be polite,
have good manners, self-deprecating humor, a
willingness to eat what's put in front of you,
and sleep where you're asked to sleep."
I mean, Tim, food is power. It's amazing
how many people will so crudely refuse a gift of
food. If you're being given food almost anywhere
in the world, it means some child is probably
not eating that day. And even if you know, and
there's been many times when I've known because of
the circumstances, that if I eat a plate offered
to me, without doubt, I'll contract giardia or
amoebic dysentery, I always eat the food. Because
you can always treat the illness, you can never
rekindle the trust that you've shattered, not
just between you and the person, but between that
person and the next outsider who will come along.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to jump back to rites of
passage for a second. Because I do feel like
young males pay the price for the void of the
no rites of passage. And women too, but they do
have that inbuilt, as you pointed out, rite of
passage, whether it's formalized in some type
of societal context or not. I'm curious how you
have, if at all, thought about rites of passage
for your own kids or how you might suggest parents
think about rites of passage. Primarily for males,
but it could also apply to females.
Wade Davis: Well, I had two girls,
and when they each got their periods,
they came to me, not to their mother.
Tim Ferriss: Why is that, do you think?
Wade Davis: You'd have to ask them, but I mean,
I had that kind of relationship with them. I mean,
what we've done, obviously, with our daughters,
we've been able to take them all around
the world. And also, while they grew up,
we own a fishing lodge, a very modest fishing
lodge, but very remote, seven hours from the
nearest town, three days drive north of Vancouver
in Tahltan country. And so while they grew up and
I was traveling a great deal for the National
Geographic, the two or three months we would
spend there every summer became the well the
family drank from for the rest of the year. And
for those months they hung out with Tahltan kids
all the time. And so they have this unbelievable
sense of the world. My daughter speaks Arabic,
one of them. I remember our house in Washington
in particular was kind of a Grand Central Station.
Everybody was free to crash there, and you never
knew who was going to turn up. I just had a
friend call me who reminded me of the day he
woke up there and found four Mongolians drinking
vodka at 6:00 a.m. in the kitchen. And one time
we had Nilda Callañaupa, this great friend of
mine, a weaver, really a national treasure,
from Cusco staying in one guest room. And
I'd forgotten to tell my daughters that a
friend of mine from Mali, Isa Mohammed, a Tuareg,
massive guy, was there for the Folklife Festival.
So they didn't know he was staying there, and
he comes up from the basement guest room in
full ritual regalia, looking like Lawrence
of Arabia. This guy, this massive guy,
much bigger than me, he comes into the kitchen,
spreads his arms across the kitchen. My girls
were eating Rice Krispies at the table, and he
just says, "Mes enfants, je suis là!" And they
just look up at this incredible African guy.
Tim Ferriss: Could you translate that, please?
Wade Davis: Yeah. "My children, I'm here."
And they just looked up at him and they said,
"Hello, sir, how are you? You must be a friend
of my father's. Can we get you some breakfast,
please?" I mean, utterly nonplussed. So those
are the kind of initiation rites — I think for
boys in the American context and culture it
really is great to find ways for them to go
away and do physical labor. This is why I
think there should be Youth Conservation
Corps in every state and national park. There's
nothing better than for a 15-year old boy with
all those hormonal spasms and all that pimply
face to just be forced to cut firewood all day.
And these kind of opportunities aren't trivial.
They create the character very young. There's no
reason whatsoever that our government in the
United States shouldn't be able to mobilize
resources that would make available to every
young American boy and girl the opportunity to
travel within America, to know another face
of America, another section of the country.
Californians to Iowa, Kansans to Miami, and so
on. And give them work to help make us a better
country, whether it's picking up plastic
or caring for the elderly, whatever it is.
Again, giving young people a sense that
they're not the center of the universe.
That they live to help others.
That we do exist as a community.
That you have to be humble. And just because
you believe it doesn't mean it's true. And that
the democratization of opinion doesn't mean
that your opinion counts as much as an elder
who has lived through life that you can't even
imagine. There are ways to make this possible,
but physical activity is the key, I
think, particularly for men. Which is why,
say what you will about the military, it has
done more good for more young men in its history.
Not that obviously we would not criticize some
of the engagements, but you know what I'm saying.
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Wade Davis: As an institution
of the nation that stands for the nation. Young
people have to learn that there's something bigger
than themselves that they need to be loyal to. And
that's not necessarily a country, it's a concept.
It's the idea of community. It's something we
really notice, Tim, in Canada, which is no perfect
place. But one of the things that is so different
in Canada is that there is really a sense of
community. We really are a social democracy. And
it creates for a different way of life. I mean,
one thing, I don't want to belabor this, but in
America, universal healthcare is seen as socialist
medicine, and healthcare in general is seen as a
uniquely medical issue. And that is to miss the
point completely. Universal healthcare, which we
have in Canada, has nothing to do with medicine.
It has everything to do with social solidarity. It
has everything to do with every Canadian knowing
that they belong, and knowing that if their kid
gets sick, they will get exactly, and I tell you,
it is exactly, the same care as any other
Canadian, including the Prime Minister. Yes,
I sometimes have to wait for medical
service in Canada, but everyone does,
but no one is left behind. And that is one of
the reasons that we have a less highly charged
society, why we seem to get along better.
Tim Ferriss: I certainly agree with that.
And I also agree with the physical labor
component and the importance of it for
boys and young men and men overall. But I think
especially in that hormonal tidal wave period,
let's just call it, from whatever it
might be, 13 to 18. And in addition to the
transcendence of the self to a larger cause, say
in a military context, it strikes me that both the
military and the physical exertion of, say, having
to chop wood all day, serve a similar purpose in
that of shared privation, which is a term you hear
in a military context. And that is a group of boys
going through some form of suffering together.
And it does seem to activate something in the
male psyche that is hard to access otherwise.
Wade Davis: One of my most memorable experiences,
when I was 20, I was just come back from
the Sierra Nevada with the mamos. And Tim
was going back to Harvard to get his degree
and I had a month off until he was going to
return. And I ran into this crazy Englishman
who had walked from the tip of South America,
and he was walking to Alaska. And he was
sending these dispatches to his newspaper,
The London Sunday Observer. And I'm not sure
what he wrote because in 18 months of walking,
he hadn't learned a word of Spanish. But anyway,
he hired me to guide him through the Darien Gap,
the only stretch of this trip —
Tim Ferriss: That's very dangerous.
Wade Davis: — that had no road. And he didn't
care that I knew nothing about the area. That
was great because he cultivated misadventures
as fodder for his books. And in the course of
that journey — it was incredible. During the rainy
season, walking in swamps up to the neck for days
at a time. At one point we got lost in the jungle
with three Kuna Indians for 12 days with no food.
I was down to 146 pounds. At one point, Sebastian
was down to 120. We had to carry the other Indian
lad. And at one point when we were at the
wit's end, I just said, "We've got to go."
And I took the gun and I walked up this trail
and I ran right into a black jaguar. And if
you ever run into a jaguar, they've got these
yellow eyes. They don't look at you, they look
through you. You feel like you've been x-rayed.
And I just looked at that incredibly beautiful
creature, and then it leapt off the road. And I
thought we had two weeks to walk to get to rescue,
but we found a way to the end of the road
that day. And it was just like a miracle. And
at the end of this extraordinary misadventure,
I got off the plane in Panama City.
I had flown out in this cramped Cessna. The girl
beside me had puked on me. Her mother turned
around to console the daughter, she puked on me.
I only had the rotten clothes on my back, $3 to
my name, and one bottle of beer this engineer
had given me. I arrived in Panama City with
nothing more than that, and no plans whatsoever,
but I had never felt more alive. I had been on
my own hero's journey and I had survived.
And that would be etched into my character.
If I could do that, I could do anything.
Tim Ferriss: This may seem — well, it's not
random because you prompted it in a way. So black
jaguars are not common as far as I know. What did
the Kuna Indians make of that black jaguar?
Wade Davis: They didn't see
it. I was way ahead of them.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just wondering, even if you told
them, if that carried any special significance.
Wade Davis: Oh, for sure. I mean, nothing is
accidental when it comes to that. When you're
with peoples like the Barasana and the Macuna,
their most profound cultural insight, one might
say, is their conviction that plants and animals
are just people in another dimension of
reality. So their hunting myths become
kind of a land management plan dictating how
people can live in the forest. So the shaman,
he's not just a priest or a physician, he's kind
of like a nuclear engineer who goes to the heart
of the reactor to reprogram the world. So there's
a constant dialogue between human beings and the
natural world, so no event has a life of its own.
Tim Ferriss: I do want to, at some point, and I'm
saying this to remind myself and maybe remind you
to remind me, about getting better at writing and
teaching yourself to write on multiple levels.
We'll get to that. But since you brought up
the people in other dimensions, effectively,
manifesting as plants and animals,
I'd like to discuss, it doesn't have to be
brief, we have as much time as we want, but
the different origin stories of this brew
called ayahuasca, which exists in many different
iterations used by many, many different tribal
groups and cultures at this point, and churches
also, syncretic religions at this point.
But I'm wondering how you would explain the
development of this particular combination
of plants. And the reason I ask is that I've
heard many different explanations for
this. So one is just trial and error
over a very long period of time. Another, on
the opposite end of the spectrum, would be,
"The plants told us." And I'm wondering how you
would explain the arrival at this combination of,
say, vine and — DMT-containing plant.
Wade Davis: Well, first of all,
one thing I've mentioned about ayahuasca or yagé
is that the idea we often have of it as we go
down to Iquitos, or Pucallpa, the healers of the
Shipibo, as if it's sort of a quest for personal
liberation, personal well-being. That's always
been there in the traditional use of hallucinogens
in South America, the traditional syncretic cult
of the cactus of the four winds and the curanderos
who use San Pedro cactus on the coast. And
certainly the popularization of ayahuasca began
with The Yagé Letters between William Burroughs —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Wade Davis: And Allen Ginsberg. And it
was Burroughs who turned up in Bogota,
goes to the Herbarium, meets who he calls Doc
Schindler, who is Schultes. And Schultes sends him
off and eventually gets him ayahuasca in Mocoa.
And on that road between Sibundoy and Mocoa in the
upper Putumayo, when I was there in the 1970s,
there were already individual healers sort of
working with the gringo trade, but also
working with individual campesinos.
And of course all of these healing practices,
the ideas that the imbalance of the individual
is treated through the medicine and
whether the imbalance is caused by
bad health, bad, poor finances, personal problems,
whatever. It's a balance the source that one gets
to. But I mentioned that only to stress that it
is completely a different situation when you get
into the heart of the Northwest Amazon, where
presumably these plants were originated, these
preparations. So for example, one of the powerful
themes that is somewhat like what the Kogi do,
this idea that human beings aren't the problem,
we're the solution because only through the human
imagination can the wonder of the natural world
become manifest, that we are the ones who have to
maintain the energetic flows of the universe.
We have this proactive role to play well in
the Northwest Amazon, it's very much that way.
I mean, the main origin myth that in one way or
another is shared by multiple cultures, speaks
of a great journey from the east up the Milk
River in sacred canoes dragged by Anaconda.
And in the canoes are all the hierarchy,
the chiefs, the wisdom keeper, the dancers, the
warriors, the slaves, and also the three vital
plants, coca, yagé, and tobacco. And these are
brought up the Milk River. And originally they
were brought up by the Ayawa, the four thunders,
these mythological culture heroes. And they
encountered a world of total devastation and they
turned that world upside down and brought order to
it by destroying the negative forces. So this idea
that humans are responsible for the equilibrium,
and then the Ayawas went up and became the stars.
And then the great mother Romi Kumu brought the
people up and the people settled each river.
And because each river was settled by a unique
canoe, each language group are related to
each other. You can't marry within your
language. So one of the extraordinary things
in the northwest, Amazon is I is linguistic
exotomy when you marry, you must marry
someone who speaks a different language,
but the use of ayahuasca is not individualistic.
It's collective at these great ceremonies that go
on for two and three days where the individuals,
the men, all the people are there, but only men
take yagé. They go through two different
kinds of ritual paraphernalia, feather work
by day by night. And they literally, by
taking ayahuasca, don't become symbols of
the ancestors. They become the ancestors
and they fly away to all the sacred sites
to pay homage to the natural world, to maintain
the harmonic balance. So the critical thing here
is that the use of the plant preparation has
nothing to do with any individual's well-being,
but rather becomes a prayer ceremony for the
collective well-being and survival of the culture.
And it becomes the mediator to the divine. And so
the kinds of things you see in the kind of gringo
ayahuasca business around Iquitos is not
traditional in that sense. Now as to how
this knowledge was discovered, I mean there
are a couple possibilities. First of all,
there is a species of Malpighiaceous vine,
Diplopterys cabrerana, which, it looks very much
like yagé and does have DMT in it. So maybe they
saw that, then they saw the opposite leaves, they
saw the Psychotria coffee plant opposite leaves.
Clearly there's experimentation going on, but
it's not just with ayahuasca, take something like
curare. The remarkable thing about curare: it's
a muscle relaxant. But to affect the muscles, it
has to get into the blood. You can drink as much
curare as you want, and if you don't have some
kind of wound in your stomach, you'll be fine.
How do you rationally explain that process
of elaboration? And you mentioned trial and
error. Well, I think statistically that is just
click exposed as a meaningless euphemism. Now,
I mentioned that story about Schultes saying the
Siona-Secoya and the 17 varieties sing to you in
a different key. Well, whatever that really
means when the people say "The plants teach
us," I'm quite prepared at this point in my life
to take them at their word. And the reason I say
that is that these men, largely men also women,
but in terms of ayahuasca, these aren't sort of
random characters. These are true natural
philosophers who understand that flora in
ways that few scientists could ever aspire to do.
They have spent their lives in wisdom, traditions,
lineages that have been taking all of this common
genius that I keep talking about, we all share as
human beings and applying it to that challenge.
I mean, for example, I mean, just jumping away for
a second. When you go to Australia, you realize
that the entire purpose of life is not to change
the world, but to do the rituals to keep the
world just as it was. Well, imagine how much
would be learned if the people of New York City
had spent all of their existence putting all of
their energy and capacity into understanding the
biological relationships of Central Park. I mean,
it'd be incredible, right? So when we say "The
plants teach us," I'm not sure what that means.
I don't quite know how it'd become operative,
but I do know, and I've had this experience
myself taking any number of psychoactive
substances that you have insights that
become almost challenging to believe in the wake
of your experience. I never understood the glory
of photosynthesis. I never appreciated the miracle
of this verse of life, this idea that water can
come together with carbon dioxide and create the
air that we breathe and the food that we eat.
I mean, that's a poetic verse every child should
have to memorize. And no politician should ever
be able to run for office if they can't recite
the formula of photosynthesis. But the point is,
I remember I took — Tim and I discovered a new
species of San Pedro cactus in 1974 in Bolivia,
and we took a big wack of it on the eastern side
of the Andes and knowing that it was safe. And
Tim and Schultes used to say Tim and I ate our
way through South America. If anything back then
had a chance to get us high, we would take it.
I know we were crazy, we were kids. As Tim and I
made ready to say goodbye to each other after over
a year and a half traveling together, we took this
extraordinary, Terence would call heroic dose of
this new species we had found. And we were up for
48 hours. And one point we just left the ground
and we were flying over the surface of the Earth.
And I looked down and I saw the Nazca Lines. And
I became convinced that that's how that explained
how these guys conceived those monumental
structures. But at that same experience, I saw
Tim fly up like Icarus to the sun and disappear.
And I knew right then he was going to die and he
would be dead in short order. In fact, from AIDS.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible. And for people who
don't have the context, the Nazca Lines, which
I've seen from the air, are something to behold.
So you see these huge depictions on the ground.
Wade Davis: There was anthropomorphic figures
that from the ground you can never make
out. But from 10,000 feet you see these
perfectly etched forms of spiders and monkeys.
Tim Ferriss: Monkeys and also someone they refer
to as E.T. because it looks bizarrely like
our modern day depictions of aliens. So go
figure that one out. Question for you about the
historic use of ayahuasca. Is it accurate to say,
or let me rephrase the question.
To what extent was ayahuasca or
yagé predominantly used for, say, hunting or
divination purposes versus healing purposes?
Wade Davis: Oh, I think obviously it depends
on the setting the culture, the moment in time.
Certainly all of these entheogens are
used in the course of healing. I mean,
the essence of the shamanic art of healing is
the idea that disease is not caused by pathogens,
but by imbalance it has to be addressed. And to
do so, the shaman must invoke some technique of
ecstasy to soar away on the wings of trance to get
into these distant metaphysical realms where he or
she can do their work of medical magical, mystical
rescues. So ayahuasca in that sense has always,
I think, been associated with healing arts.
But again, in the context of periodic rituals
and ceremonies, as I mentioned with
the Barasana that we filmed actually
the celebration of cassava women,
the kind of fertility ritual there,
it's a journey of the community, the journey,
the community comes together in ritual.
I mean, this idea of communities coming together
in ritual doesn't have to involve these sacred
plants. I mean, in the Andes, for example, in the
community of Chinchero, once each year outside of
Cusco, the fastest young boy is given the honor
of becoming a woman. And he puts on the clothing
of a sister and he leads all able-bodied men on
a run. But it's not your ordinary run. You start
off at 11,500 feet, run 2,000 feet down to the
base of the sacred mountain, and then you run to
16,000 feet. And then you drop down to the sacred
valley and cross two more soaring Indian ridges.
And you're running the boundaries of the community
land. But the wonderful metaphor is that you
go into the mountain as an individual, but
through sacrifice, which means in Latin to
make sacred from pure exhaustion, you merge into
a single community that once again has expressed
both its ownership but also its obligations to
land. I did that race when I was 48 years old,
the only outsider ever to do it. I trained
six months with an African American boxer
in DC in a gym. And I only got through the day
by chewing more coca leaves than anyone in the
5,000 year history of the plant.
Tim Ferriss: But yeah, it does help.
I will say that of every remedy that was offered
to me that I certainly tested when I was suffering
from altitude sickness in South America,
the only thing that fixed it and fixed it
very quickly was coca leaf tea. It was remarkable.
Wade Davis: It's a miracle. Well, I mean coca mean
just without diverting ourselves from ayahuasca
prayer. But I mean, the thing about coca Tim,
it's not just that coca is not cocaine, it's not
just that it's been misunderstood or whatever. The
real tragedy is that humanity as a whole has been
robbed of the benefits of this incredible plant.
If you go back to the 19th century when physicians
were studying coca, heralding its virtues in a
non-judgmental context with open access to the
leaves, time and again, they would be befuddled
by its activity. They called it the stimulant
that wasn't a stimulant. In other words, you
would chew the leaves and you felt nothing except
the consequences of having done so. You suddenly
felt a slight elevation of mood and the ability to
concentrate and focus, perhaps a drop in appetite,
but you had no sense of the kind of charge you
get when even you drink a strong cup of coffee.
And this, of course, is what makes the
plant so perfect for our modern age. I mean,
who wouldn't like to have access to a substance
that gently elevated their mood that was utterly
benign. It had 5,000 years of safe use that was
a sacred plant that allowed you to focus on your
damn laptop without getting distracted to email.
That allowed you to overcome that slight inertia
that keeps you from writing that first sentence
of your report. And then you suddenly discover
at the end of the day, you've been doing this so
productively for eight hours and you just go home
and you go to sleep, or you have your meal or
whatever with no side effects whatsoever. And
you can do it again the next day and the next day
and next day. And before you know it, you see that
your productivity, your well-being, your health
has soared. People always say to me, "How on Earth
have you written 23 books?" And I just wink.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, well, I'd love to open a
bottle of wine and talk about that wink sometime.
Certainly. Because I would like to do some more
writing myself. Let me come back to ayahuasca just
for a moment. Because you mentioned the trinity in
many of these cultures of coca, yagé, and tobacco,
and I'm fascinated by tobacco. That's a longer
story for maybe another time, but they have read,
I think his name is, I'm probably mispronouncing
this, but Johannes Wilbert in his book.
Wade Davis: Oh, he was? Oh, he was
wonderful. Oh, good for you.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing book.
Wade Davis: He's a beautiful man. He just died.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Wade Davis: He was one of my great mentors.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no kidding. All right.
Wade Davis: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So tobacco. Yeah. So tobacco
is a whole separate chapter that I'd
love to talk about for hours. But another
trinity I've I've seen mentioned is cassava,
ayahuasca, and then palm for different reasons.
I have read a number of papers, or at least one
paper, I should say that in the hunting context,
also mentioned use of ayahuasca
or dosing of hunting dogs with
ayahuasca. And I'm wondering if that can
be explained simply by hyper dilatation
of the pupils, maybe better hunting at night,
something along those lines, or if there's another
explanation that people doing it would offer.
Wade Davis: Yeah, I mean, these things don't
necessarily have a practical utility because
someone feeds their dog either Datura or
ayahuasca. Doesn't imply that the dog therefore
must get some attribute from that. That dose,
I mean. It could easily be a kind of magical
idea or a metaphysical idea, a transcendent idea.
But there is, there isn't that separation
from human beings and animals in that
sense. So there's a lot of that goes on in the
Amazon. I mean, you mentioned yucca. I mean,
one of the fascinating things is that there
are many female anthropologists today,
but in the early years it was obviously dominated
by men. And in the northwest Amazon in particular,
there's a very clear division of labor. I would
never say that women are subordinate, on the
contrary, but there's a very clear division of
labor. And for example, the gardens, the chakras,
are very much of the domain of the women.
I once made a mistake in the long house
saying in front of all the men to all the
women. "Boy, I'd love you to take me to the
garden and show me your cultivated plants." And
everybody laughed their heads off because the
gardens are also where you go to make love. So
I'd essentially propositioned every woman in the
maloca. But it does suggest that the realm of the
woman is not readily accessible to men. I mean,
I've often had people say to me, "All your
books, it seems to be a man's world." Well,
it's a man's world in the sense that I'm a man,
but that doesn't mean I'm not respectful of the
woman's sphere. And one of the exciting
studies that was done with a Barasana
by two great ethnographers, Stephen
Hugh-Jones and his wife Christine Hugh-Jones.
While Stephen was looking at the Yurupary cult in
ayahuasca, and his book was published as The Palm
and the Pleiades, Christine was hanging for all
those years with the women. And her book, From the
Milk River, shows that the preparation of bitter
manioc is in wrapped in as much cosmology, as much
significance as ayahuasca. I mean, if you think
about it in the Northwest Amazon, the main food is
cassava. And cassava's made from bitter manioc or
tapioca. And it's an incredibly elaborate process
that the women have to do every day, transforming
a poisonous a root crop into the daily food of
their children. And it's not surprising that
the equipment and the process is absolutely
celebrated in mythological terms. And that was
Christine's great contribution of that book.
Tim Ferriss: So I will segue to the question on
writing because I selfishly also want to know the
answer, but I would like to spend a little
bit more time on the sphere of psychedelics
with your experience of traveling over
experientially after taking this new species of
the San Pedro cactus, and then seeing your friend
flying into the sun and having this realization.
How do you explain these phenomena, those types
of experiences, which seem to happen with some
degree of regularity and shared visions,
at least purportedly shared visions with
ayahuasca and things at this time?
Wade Davis: Well, I think this is
why human beings in all places for all time have
been fascinated by these entheogens because they
really do reveal realms of ethereal wonder. And
as you well know in such a way that you almost
are left feeling that the world, lovely as it
is that we dwell in, our ordinary consciousness
is almost like a crude facsimile of a realm
that is beyond our imaginings at the other
side of consciousness, if you want. And I think
that, as I've always said, I mentioned earlier,
these sort of great social transformations
that can leave us, I think, hopeful.
But when we look at the ingredients and the recipe
that allowed for those social changes, there's
one ingredient that we tend to expunge from the
record, which is the fact that millions of us in
that era, the '60s and '70s, took psychedelics.
And I don't think I would think the way I think,
I don't think I would write the way I write. I
don't think I would understand cultural relativism
as I do. I don't think I would be drawn to nature
as I am. I don't think I treat women the way I do,
understand gay men and women be as tolerant
and open as I've obviously am and have always
been. If I hadn't taken psychedelics. I mean,
I always make this joke that her parents said,
"Don't take these things, you'll never come
back the same." And the poor parents didn't
understand that was the entire point of the
exercise. We didn't want to come back the same.
We wanted to come back transformed. I mean,
I think this was the key to my generation. We
all suffered from Baudelaire's malady, a horror
of home. We grew up in a world that we found to
be problematic, or at least I did in terms of our
treatment of the environment, the way we treated
women or the way we treated people of color,
the way that gay men and women were treated.
And I went out looking for a more authentic
life in a different world. And so there was
almost no separation between my desire
to know other cultures and other places,
and knowing other realms of consciousness just
went hand in hand with that. And I think in a way,
looking back, this sort of became the multiple
elements of what was in effect my hero's journey.
I set off with no plans except to be away
for at least a year. I had enough money to
stay with a budget of $3 a day. My only
promise was that I was not going to come
back to the United States until Richard Nixon
was no longer president. And I waited them out
and I was gone 15 months. But looking back on
those months, it was an absolute initiation.
And I came back a different person, which is of
course what one wants to do when one travels.
Tim Ferriss: You have said that psychedelics
were useful to you when you were young,
but later on more, perhaps, disorienting
and less helpful. Do you still
feel that way? That's an accurate statement?
Wade Davis: Yeah, I think everybody, ever
since Leary and Alpert and Andy Weil began
sharing this concept of set and setting,
we've known that these substances kind of invoke,
they create a, they're completely neutral.
They create a kind of template upon which beliefs,
expectations, one's one set and the setting of the
experience can play roles. And I personally
found, and I really believe in the Vedic
notion of the stages of life. You're a child,
you're a young man, you become a householder,
and then you are free to wander as a sadhu, as
you approach the end of your life. And I think
one wants to try to be in sync with those stages,
if you will. And when I was a young kid trying in
high school to deconstruct the world around me,
I loved to smoke pot because we were just you
know how it was you were 15, 16, just laughing
at the world and all the idiocies around you.
And similarly psychedelics just opened my mind.
I mean, these are powerful forces. Let's just
remember that because of psychedelics, The
Beatles went from "She Loves You" to "Tomorrow
Never Knows" in two years. Think about that. And
then what I found, Tim, is to be honest with you,
I lived such a crazy life. I mean, I didn't have
a home. I owned nothing but artifacts and books.
I was on the go constantly. What I owned
was in storage. I was the amount of travel,
it was all exciting, but at the time it was also
very kind of confusing. I was very ambitious to
know what my destiny would be. I knew I didn't
really want to be an academic. I love botany,
but I wasn't going to be a botanist and so
on. And jumping ahead, it was when I wrote The
Serpent and the Rainbow that things clicked.
I said, "Oh, that's what I am. I can write."
But there was a very powerful year for me where
I was living in France after I'd finished The
Serpent and the Rainbow, but before it had come
out, and I was writing my PhD and living with the
French girlfriend in a small village of 26 people
in Provence in the Alps, the Low Alps. And I got
a phone call in the night that my father had
died. And I immediately came home to Canada. And
that year, I can't remember the order that this
happened, but I had a letter waiting for me from
Gail. And in coming home from France, I walked
out of a relationship of five years with this
older French woman, got home. There was a letter
waiting from Gail, who is now my wife of 35 years.
Within a year, my father had died, I graduated
from Harvard after 18 years of it being my home,
I had met Gail, she was
pregnant with the first child,
my book had come out and I had made a
fortune, I bought a house with cash,
and I was suddenly a father and a husband
and living in British Columbia in a home
and writing a book about Schultes, having lost my
father earlier in the year. I mean all of that,
also, that year, the Hollywood
movie came out based on the book.
It was like the I-Ching. My world turned over
and I found myself, once I became a father,
a whole different set of priorities.
Now I had successfully built a world.
I revered that world. I lived by that world, and
I didn't really at that critical time when I was
a new husband, a new father, getting my career
underway, establishing a reputation as a speaker,
living in this little house on a hill,
writing this biography of Schultes,
that I had no idea whether it would be successful
and become almost a cult book that it is.
The point is that at that time, it was
not the time to be blowing open my mind,
right. On the contrary, right. It was a time
to consolidate, to take all I had learned,
all my vagabond dreams and pull them together
as I kind of wove the fabric of my own
individual life. And since then, I've taken
ayahuasca largely to sort of remember what
it was like when I was writing One River.
And I've taken a few other things. I could
easily find myself experimenting once again as
particularly as I get older and perhaps [am]
approaching death. It's one of the things that
I think that these psychedelics are incredibly
useful. Not to eliminate fear of death, but to
help make it seem natural and normal — which
it is. So it's not, again, and I'm not here
judging. I mean, I think if you look back,
Leary, for example, or John Lennon for that
matter, I would argue took way too much LSD,
whereas George Harrison and Ram Dass famously,
as they wrote, got the message and hung up.
In other words, I'm not sure how many times
you need to take these substances to learn what
you're going to learn from them. Now that that's
me. I mean, other people find these to be part
of an ongoing journey and engagement. One of the
things I do find interesting is how the gestalt on
ayahuasca has changed. If you had asked
me, Tim, I first took ayahuasca in 1974,
and if you had asked me then, which of all
the plants that I was becoming familiar with
would be the one that 45 years later would be in
every hallway of America? I would never have said
ayahuasca. I mean, as Tim used to say, ayahuasca
is about many things. Pleasant isn't one of them.
And when you talk to the indigenous people,
it's fascinating. They use language like
"You're the warrior confronting the
horror. You're nursing at the breast
of Jaguar mother when she rips you from her kit
and flings you into a pit of poisonous vipers."
I mean, once was with Randy Borman, and we
took ayahuasca with the Cofán and we had a
very interesting kind of spontaneous session after
the experience. And I was asking, I said to these
men I'd been through the journey with. I said, "I
got to tell you, this stuff scares the hell out of
me." And they all looked at me, said, "Of course
it does. That's what it's supposed to do." And
so what I find interesting is that people of your
generation and younger are all sort of reporting
how kind of transcendent and blissful and
wonderful ayahuasca was. I mean, the last time I
took it, just to try to remember what it was like
to write about it, I remember sort of clinging to
my wife for about 24 hours. But anyway, I mean,
this is all in the realm of set and setting. I do
find that I prefer something like San Pedro cactus
for the visceral connection to the natural world.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I feel not that dissimilar
from your description, or the impetus behind
The Wayfinders, that not polemics, not politics,
but storytelling is what you could use to drive a
change in culture. I think that ayahuasca,
maybe counterintuitively because of the
just awful experiences that many people
will have are challenging, let's just say,
has all the ingredients for great storytelling.
You have a group setting. You have, in most cases,
at least in the United States, an imported exotic
shaman who is running the show. You have shared
privation in the form of vomiting and God knows
what else. And you have just the perfect cocktail
for word of mouth in so many ways. And I think
for that reason it has traveled and become so
sexy in a sense, unlike, say, mushrooms that in
the United States, these Psilocybe mushrooms,
are taken in a very recreational setting
which would be very dissimilar from, say,
the Mazatec traditional use. But that never
made the hop, it never crossed the border.
Wade Davis: I always wonder if — in the morning
after taking ayahuasca, I always just feel happy
to be alive. And I'm sometimes with these young
people, where they're so happy just to have gotten
through it. But anyway, it's a phenomenon.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I think there's also a
selection bias for the highlight reels.
It's much like if you're part of a religion,
meaning I'm using "religion" in quotation marks,
that is dietary focused. And if your hair starts
falling out because you're following some
weird diet, you don't want to confess that
to the group because you'll be ostracized.
So you just don't talk about how, "Oh,
I felt destabilized for two weeks." But you do
tell them like, "Oh, I had this insight about my
dad and things are so much better now." Anyway,
I'll put that aside. Let's talk about writing.
I really enjoy your writing. It is poetic. It has
a very nuanced play of words and wordsmithing and,
in the course of doing research for this
conversation, came across you mentioning on
several occasions that you were forced to teach
yourself to write well. And I'm most curious,
not necessarily why that was the case,
but what the process looked like. How
did you teach yourself to write well?
Wade Davis: It's good. I mean, a lot of
aspiring writers out there. I mean, I wasn't aware
of myself having been anything like a writer in,
say, high school. I mean, I later looked back
and was surprised to learn that I won the English
prize and the history prize. And I did have
a tremendous foundation in English grammar.
I went to a private school in Montreal in Grade 7
where we had to memorize the 120 sentence errors
in English grammar. And literally we got whacked
if we didn't know them. That may sound silly,
but grammar is the architecture of writing. I
mean, if you don't understand basic grammar,
you can never be a writer and I have just an
incredible, intuitive understanding of the
grammar of the English language because of that
experience when I was young and what happened.
And I always kept journals when I was on the road
and I certainly was deeply impressed and I had
mentors like the poet Gary Snyder. I never went
anywhere without one of Gary's volumes of poems
in my backpack. Peter Matthiessen. A number of
writers that I really admired. And I was always
drawn to the genre of travel books because
that's sort of what I was doing, who I was.
But what actually happened with the case of The
Serpent and the Rainbow is, as I said earlier in
the podcast, the zombie research was funded
by Dr. Kline. They set up a dummy foundation
called the International Psychiatric Research
Foundation. And literally, at the beginning,
if I needed $5,000, $10,000 by Wednesday I
just had to call New York by Monday night.
And I never knew who was the benefactor, but it
turned out to be a wonderful man, David Merrick,
the Broadway producer who at that time had just
had a huge success on Broadway with 42nd Street.
And David had also done, obviously, a number of
feature films and he must have been hearing from
Dr. Kline about my misadventures and he saw
a film from the very start in this. And then,
again, as I mentioned earlier, in an unbelievable
24 hours, Dr. Kline died during routine heart
surgery and Mr. Merrick had a debilitating
stroke so I literally went overnight from
being flushed with support to having none. And I
did apply to all the standard research sources,
various grants, foundations, but they
all take months and months to let you
know whether you're going to get the money or not.
And I had guided that British journalist through
the Darién Gap. His name was Sebastian Snow, and
he had written a really dreadful book about his
journey called The Rucksack Man, and he actually
lifted whole passages out of my diaries into this
book, which actually was a fair exchange because
it was the first time I saw my writing in print,
albeit lifted from my journals. Actually, I was
able to give him something worth saying because
I spoke Spanish whilst hanging with the Indians
all the time. He knew nothing about where he
was. He said if he spoke the Queen's English
loud enough they'd understand. He was just a
completely eccentric guy. He went mad, actually,
in Costa Rica, but that's a whole 'nother story.
But I thought, "Well, my God, if he could
write a book, I can write a book." So
that was an idea. And then he generously
gave me the address of his literary agent
in London. I walked off the street and said, "I've
got a couple of ideas." And this Englishman looked
down his nose, as they often do to Canadians,
"Well, there might be something in that zombie
thing." And before I knew it, I'd dictated the
story into a typewriter what happened to me,
had it transcribed, typed by Ed Wilson's,
Professor Wilson's wonderful, the late E.O.
Wilson's secretary. And I had this big 150-page
thing and I gave it in as a book proposal,
got a contract for what then was an enormous
amount of money for me, $35,000, spent it on
some fun in Paris with a girlfriend, and then
used the rest of it to finish the research.
And then I had to actually write a book. And I
wrote two chapters in Haiti. I had malaria and
hepatitis at the same time, and I was really
sick. And I wrote two chapters that I thought
was the best thing since the Bible and I sent it
to the editor and he sent it back to me and said,
"Try again." And so then I left the university
and a very dear friend of mine plucked me out
of Haiti and brought me to her beautiful farm
in Virginia to both get well but also to write
the book. And I stayed there working
in a slave cabin for seven months. And
I had a great story to tell. I had lived this
story, I just had to find the way to tell it.
So what I did — and no one gave me this idea
and I certainly had never taken a creative
writing course. I mean, most creative writing
courses are taught by people who are teaching
creative writing courses because they can't write
creatively otherwise they'd be not doing that,
they'd be writing books. But that may be a
little harsh. But all of us, lots of times,
have to get academic jobs, don't get me wrong. But
what I did is I just took all my favorite books,
Hemingway, for example, for dialogue. No
one's better. Isak Dinesen for landscape.
Lawrence Durrell in The Alexandria Quartet. How
do you evoke the exoticism of a place as surreal
as Haiti? Well, how about Alexandria in
the 1940s? Carpentier for mystical thing.
And this pile by my typewriter kept changing
and so on but it was always there and I never
obviously copied or plagiarized, but as I was
trying to tell my story and I was stuck on how to
do it, what language to use, I would just pick
up any book randomly and read for a while. And
it was just weird. Almost like by osmosis I would
— and I was often writing at night. I had lots
of coca and I was in this creative space.
And, again, one thing that I think a lesson
of all that is in the end, I wrote that book in
seven months and it was edited in a single day,
and it came out and it sold 500,000 copies.
Tim Ferriss: Hold on, hold on, hold on. You say,
"Edited in a single day?"
Wade Davis: Oh,
yeah. Almost no editing whatsoever.
Tim Ferriss: All right, I got it. Got it.
Wade Davis: No, what I mean by that is, I mean,
look, there's lots of different ways of writing.
Some people like to spit out a first draft, as
they say, or just puke it onto the page. Well,
I've just never understood how you could
make something beautiful of puke. So I,
to my detriment perhaps, am a much more laborious
writer and I've never done a second draft of a
book. I do that in a way as I'm going through,
as I write a paragraph, I'm paying attention.
I think writing's analogous to sculpture, you've
got to pay attention. Barbara Tuchman, the great
historian, had a little note above her typewriter,
"Will they turn the page?" And you have to create
rhythms in every line. You have to end every
paragraph with something that's going to make the
reader want — and it becomes unconscious, right?
But at the same time you're paying attention to
the cadence of every word, at least I am. And
that's when you talk about lyricism and that
was a skill I had to learn. In the early days
— it's very funny, my wife wouldn't bother to
edit or look at anything I write anymore, we've
been married too long, but in the early days she
was wonderful at not editing per se. She never
added any words or deleted anything, but she had
a little stamp that we called the puke meter. And
if I had a passage where I went beyond lyricism to
purple prose, she'd just stamp it, a little face
like someone throwing up. And that was really
wonderful because she was a great reader and you
learned you can always go out on the lyrical edge,
if you will, because you can always pull it
back, but you can't bring spirit to dry prose.
It's interesting. I mean, like everything else,
you get better and better the more you do it. Now
I write bizarrely effortlessly. I mean, no one
writes effortlessly. Hemingway said, "Anybody
who says they write easily is either a bad
writer or a liar." But I certainly don't — also,
I've never mistook activity for results because
I've been self-employed most of my life and I've
never indulged writer's block. Can you imagine
if a plumber came to your home, looked at you,
and suddenly patted their brow and said, "Just
can't do it today. I've got plumber's block."
You'd call the bloody police, right? No, writing's
a craft. You get up in the morning and you do it.
But one of the things that really was amazing
to me, a real turning point in my life, having
been raised in that kind of simple middle-class
world where creativity happens to someone else,
The Beatles are creative, Leonard Bernstein is
creative, whatever. When I finally understood
that creativity is not the motivation of action,
it's a consequence of action. If you don't do,
you can't create. So that insight and acting on
the insight changed my life. I never sat around
to wait for permission to write about any subject.
People will say, "Oh, I can't write about World
War I because I'm a botanist." No, you apply the
same research skills that you used to write about
the Haitian zombie to understanding the essence
of British culture in Edwardian England. And in
the same token, you can't be a photographer if
you don't take pictures. The way you become a
better photographer is to take more and more
images and to study the work of the masters.
That's what I always would say to a young
person. If you want to write non-fiction,
find the non-fiction that you think is the best
going and pay attention. Don't just read it,
study it. It's the same thing with music. When
you listen to any of these great characters
from Jimmy Page to the beloved and late
Jeff Beck, just terrible he passed away,
they always talk about how they mimed the work of
every other blues player before them. Practice,
practice, practice. I mean, Jerry Garcia never
had a guitar out of his hands, nor did Hendrix.
So you just have to do it and then ask. It's that
classic idea. Do what needs to be done and only
then ask whether it was permissible or possible.
One of the things that I've found, Tim, about life
is that at every single stage of life there's
someone telling you you shouldn't do something
and nobody wants you to change. In my case it was
like, "You're from Canada. What's wrong with the
University of — why do you have to go to Harvard?"
"Wait a minute, you're supposed to be a lawyer.
What's this anthropology thing?" "Wait a minute,
you're an...? What's this botany thing?" "We just
came back from the Amazon. What's this Vodou
thing?" "Wait a minute. How can you go work on
a logging camp? Your father just spent a half his
money sending you to this fancy school." "Wait,
you've been in a logging camp. Why should you
be a park ranger?" "Wait a minute, you..." It's
always like that and you just cannot look
behind you. I remember our mutual friend,
Mark Plotkin, once told me in the early days,
"The problem with climbing up the flagpole is
that there's always somebody looking up your
butt." By the way, that's a classic Mark line.
Tim Ferriss: That is a classic Mark
line. That is a very classic Mark line.
Well, I must say, Wade, this is an extremely
enjoyable conversation for me. I'm taking a lot
of notes. There are many other questions that I
would love to ask, but I think I'll make it not so
much dealer's choice, but guest's choice. So let
me offer three options for wrapping up and then
I would love to have you pick.
Wade Davis: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: So the first option, which is
actually a question that Mark suggested although
I would also love to know the answer, and that
is, why has Harvard not maintained their role as
a leader in ethnobotany? So that's option one.
Option two is you attended and spoke at Dennis
McKenna's ESPD55 conference, and I've had
Dennis on the podcast as well. What can
you tell us about the current and future
use of infusions by western societies?
And then the last option, which just came to
mind because Kurt Vonnegut, I think, separates
the brain vomit first draft and then refine folks
as swoopers and then I think folks who operate
more like yourself as plotters, I want to say.
And I tend to write more similar to how you write,
not to compare my writing to yours, but
I tend to rework and rework and rework.
But that only works for me if I have a very
reliable outline. So I was going to ask you
about your outlining process when writing.
Wade Davis: Well, if you don't mind, I'd
much rather talk about writing
actually, if you do the third one.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's do
it. Yeah, yeah, let's do it.
Wade Davis: I think all writers discover their
own kind of methods by definition. And what I do,
and the strength of my books and the way that
some people might even call them too dense,
is that they're incredibly deeply researched.
The book we haven't really talked about,
Into the Silence, which actually won the prize for
the top book in the English language, which was
then called the Samuel Johnson Prize, that took
12 years. And in that process I bought 600 books.
With either myself or my research assistant we
visited 57 archives, multiple journeys to Tibet.
I had the spiritual autobiography, the namthar
of Dzatrul Rinpoche from Rongbuk translated by
monks in Kathmandu. I spent weeks myself in the
monastery, established by his spiritual heir, just
to know what Rongbuk would've looked like in 1921
and so on. So just insane amounts of research.
And then what I do is I go through all that
material, and in the case, obviously, of
the Everest book there's files of
original letters and reports. And then
I create what I call work points. I don't
read the books, I don't scan the books or
skim the books. I think I'd say I mind the
books. I know, for example, that I want to
deal at some point with how Edwardian
women or women during the Great War
dealt with the experience of death, as one
example. Well, I know that in my head that's
there so as I go through all the material,
I start constructing these work points.
And that work point could be anything on a
theme, homosexuality in the 1920s, or the
Buddhist science of mind, and the work points
can become a huge number. But then everything I
then subsequently source, I know there's a work
point sheet, a document to put it in, right?
And so then that's how I distill
all this research into a manageable
set of sources. And when I write the book, I
never go back unless I specifically need to for
one point or something to the original sources.
And at the same time, I find, Tim, you might
try this, that the act of doing that unveils
the outline of the book, right? I don't think
you can simply, "I want to write a book on
coca. Oh, here, it's going to be chapter one,
chapter two." I mean, these book proposals from
publishers are so idiotic because you can't really
do that. The book unveils itself. I mean, I'm sure
you've had this experience. You think, "Oh my God,
I've got to talk about this element of his life.
It's going to be boring. I'll have to cover it in
10 pages." And you discover you can actually
say all that you need to say in a paragraph.
Or inversely you discover, "Oh my God,
Schultes..." Perfect example is Schultes
in One River. "Oh, I knew he was involved
in this rubber crisis in World War II. Oh
it's going to be so boring but I've got to cover
it." Turns out to be the most exciting part of
his career and of the book, right? So the books
have a way of unfolding like that. And I find,
and I know some other writers don't —
David McCullough, the great writer —
Tim Ferriss: Incredible writer.
Wade Davis: — starts to write his books before he
has even finished the research, which I can't do.
Tim Ferriss: I can't do that either.
Wade Davis: I feel it's like I have to have all
the stuff before me before I begin to assemble
it into the writing. And I don't think it's a
slow process. I actually write very quickly.
Tim Ferriss: May I ask a follow-up question
though? When you have your work points,
do you organize them thematically into some type
of, not chronological, but order that you intend
to follow as you piece those points into prose?
Wade Davis: Well, yes and no. I mean, with the
case of Into the Silence, for example, I had to
have one whole work point, as I call it, on just
the pure chronology of the battles because I was
dealing with all these men who fought all over the
place. I had to just really know what happened
at each battle. But to give you an idea of this
research, there were 26 men who went to Everest
on those first expeditions, '21, 1922, 1924.
Six of them missed the War. Sandy Irvine, too
young. Longstaff, too old. One a school teacher,
another a diplomat. But 20 saw the worst of the
fighting. And there were many other men. And I
set out to find out where each one of those
21 men, it turned out to be, had been every
single day of the four years and four months
of the First World War and I did it. I did it.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, that's an amazing test.
Wade Davis: Do you know what? It might be fun,
Tim, sometime when we're not just doing this
kind of podcast, if you're interested, we could
get on call together for 10 minutes, I could
literally show you some of these work points.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, please, I would love that.
Wade Davis: I do it with my graduate students.
It's a really helpful way — and then
you have things pop up. For example,
that question of women's relationship to the war.
Well, you could write out 10 pages about that and
never achieve anything like a single line from
Diana Manners who said that, "By the end of 1916,
every boy I had ever danced with was dead." Right?
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Wade Davis: And you're looking for those. And the
other thing I call, Tim, is wow points. This is
really important. If you're reading along, like
I was reading Max Hastings, a great historian,
I really love his books, he wrote a book
about the last year of the Pacific War and
the overwhelming dominance of the Americans and
one of the statistics that just blew my mind,
and I'll give you this as a quiz.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Wade Davis: For every four pounds of equipment,
food, gas, bullets, grenades, everything,
per capita, the Japanese Empire of the Sun got
to a frontline soldier per capita, how many
pounds did we get? And across 13,000 kilometers of
ocean. As an American, you're going to love this.
Tim Ferriss: I have no idea.
I won't even hazard a guess.
Wade Davis: No, come on, you've got to guess.
Tim Ferriss: So, okay, so give me
the question one more time.
Wade Davis: Okay. For every
four pounds of equipment —
Tim Ferriss: Four pounds.
Wade Davis: — per capita, not — and that means
for all the stuff they sent to the soldiers.
Tim Ferriss: All the stuff.
Wade Davis: Everything from
Tokyo or wherever it came from. For every
four pounds the Japanese got to a soldier,
how many pounds did America get to a soldier?
Tim Ferriss: Okay, I'm just going to throw
a number out there. It might be
overestimating. I'll say 40 pounds.
Wade Davis: Two tons.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Wade Davis: You see? So, when I'm reading
along like that, I go, "Wow," as you'd go,
"Wow." And you file it away. And before you know
it, you're writing a piece in Rolling Stone about
the unraveling of America and you want to speak
about how extraordinarily powerful America was
industrially in World War II. They come back to
you, they come back to you. But the key thing
I find, Tim, is if you're reading and something
blows your mind, that's why I call it wow points,
it's going to blow the mind of the reader.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Wade Davis: And you want to make
sure that you find a way to get
all those wow points into your manuscript.
Tim Ferriss: How do you file your wow points
or just make these available?
Wade Davis: In Word documents.
Tim Ferriss: In Word documents.
Wade Davis: But yeah, and like
Nancy Manners, I get that thing about, "Everybody
I danced with was dead." Well, that would be filed
away in Women in the War, something like that.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Wade Davis: I'd be happy, off record, out of
office hours kind of thing, just when you got
a moment and we might be able to pull them up
and it's good exercise. It's really helpful.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I would love to do
it. That's a very generous offer.
Wade Davis: It's your only way.
Tim Ferriss: My answer is yes.
Wade Davis: Well, it's the only way to
deal with the body of material. I mean,
this whole wall of my office here is
books that I bought for that one book.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Yes. So I would love to
do that. That's a very generous offer and
you've been very generous with your time. I
appreciate you being so game to go two and
a half hours. I could go another two and a
half hours, but maybe we'll save that for a
round two if this torture wasn't too bad.
Wade Davis: No, it's fine. And it's been
a lot of fun. And you asked at the very
beginning. What you did is exactly what I
was hoping you'd do. It was fun.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, amazing.
Wade Davis: It wasn't work. It was a
conversation, my friend. Very kind of you.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I loved it. And I hope
we get to meet in person, but before then,
we could certainly have a phone call. I would
love to see your work points and your flow.
Is there anything you would like to mention,
call attention to? Any request of the audience
you'd like to make before we come to the close?
Wade Davis: No, I mean, not really. I mean, it's
nice that you can plug the Magdalena book at the
introduction, but other than that, that's fine.
Unless there's something you want me to say.
Tim Ferriss: No, no, you've done more than
enough. And I will just say thank you
very much. And to everybody listening,
we will link to all of the books, all of the
references, many, many. If not, we will attempt
to get all of the things that were mentioned in
this conversation in the show notes as per usual
at tim.blog/podcast. And, wow, Wade Davis, ladies
and gentlemen. And thanks everybody for tuning in.